the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
Legends are battling over the boards at
Champions Showdown chess 9lx in St Louis
some of the best players on the planet
are showcasing their talents at one of
the world's favorite chess variants
chess 960. the 13th world champion Gary
Kasparov looks to be in Peak form
winning two games and drawing another
for Clear lead over the field the back
ranks are random so anything can happen
day two of Chess 9lx coming up next
thank you
foreign
has brought a lot of exciting chess in
this awesome Tournament of chess 9lx the
players have mentioned how amazing this
variant is and how much they're looking
forward to the tournament I'm super
excited I hope you guys at home are as
well let's go into the studio and get
today's round started
welcome to Saint Louis the home of Chess
in America is the San Luis chess club
presents chess 9lx day one was all about
Gary Kasparov coverage of the second day
starts right now
hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us I'm International Master
nazify kids and I'm here with
Grandmaster yeah it was so much fun
yesterday boy that went by fast didn't
it though those three rounds just like
that great stuff hello everyone and
Welcome to our live broadcast of
chess 9lx the 13th world champion Gary
Kasparov and set a blistering Pace
scoring two and a half points out of
three but his game against Ray Robson
was simply masterful it was great stuff
Nasi what is chess 9lx
support my viewers it was invented by
Bobby Fisher in 1996. originally named
Fisher random also known as chess 960
named for the 960 possible starting
positions because there are restrictions
for example you want to make sure that
you have Bishops of opposite colors and
that you don't put two light squared
Bishops for example to start the game
the king in order to Castle queenside or
kingside must be placed between the two
Rooks and for this event the starting
position will be received 15 minutes
before the start of play for each round
now tell us about the standings after
the first day of play right let's take a
look after three rounds we have a soul
leader Gary Kasparov can he keep up this
blistering Pace we'll see and close the
following with two points levona ronian
and Sam Seville
Sam's heavy I'm very pleased to be at
the top and with 50 so far Hikaru
Nakamura Fabiano caruana Wesley so and
Sam Shanklin Ray Robson will be looking
to write the ship and tell us about the
format
right so it's a 10 play around robin
tournament with a rapid time control 20
minutes with 5 Second increments because
it's 10 players it's a nine rounds event
we're going to be playing three days
three rapid games per day where in the
second day and in chess 960 the
background pieces are randomized and new
starting position is drawn before each
round but every player starts with the
same starting position and there will be
a playoff if there is a tie for first
place outstanding and as always we're
very fortunate to have Christian in
studio good to see you Christian good to
see you guys welcome back chess fans 2
Day 2 here in St Louis for the chess 9lx
event an amazing event up to this point
and I have to say day one did not
disappoint we've had so much blood on
the board so many decisive games in fact
let's take a look at the exact numbers
out of 15 games we had four white
victories four black victories and seven
draws more decisive results than Ross
that's a combination between the time
format and of course chess 9lx but it
was all in fact let's take a look at
what happened in round two in terms of
decisive games in round two as you can
see and as we have discussed yesterday
as well aronian Wesley so and carwana
dismantled their opposition very very
quickly 22 moves for Iranian only 13
moves for uh Wesley so and 25 moves for
Fabiano caruana just an incredible Pace
but guess who was the man that was
setting up that pace it was this
Legendary player Gary Kasparov in round
one with the black pieces he defeated
Wesley so in round through a difficult
game against Hikaru Nakamura he managed
to save that and save half a point in
that particular game and in round three
a brilliant victory that you Yasser
highlighted at the beginning of the show
against Ray Robson what a game that was
and in fact we did catch up with Gary in
an interview after the games watch Gary
I asked you yesterday after the ultimate
moves event how are you feeling and you
said that I'm feeling the pieces right
now you definitely showed that in
today's games and I have to say that
last game it was just a masterpiece give
us your emotions right now look you know
I
I think that somehow you know I'm
receiving back you know the points that
I lost last year is it because it's if
you remember the the first day last year
or so I had a bad problem slightly
better game against live on which I lost
very very badly and then two winning
positions against uh uh farby uh first I
guess uh
so I started there out of three so I
think it had a huge effect on me so what
happened what's happening now is that I
decided that you know I have to cross my
hand is this my brains are not as fast
as it used to be but hand is still there
you know so and uh the last game you
mentioned just you know I knew it was
right so they said yeah just I played
very quickly at the end because
everything went you know just in the
right position found every piece found
the right spot so that's the end
and there is a confident and In-Shape
Gary Casper of is a ferocious competitor
guys
yes he is and when he's on a roll he can
be so formidable uh Nasi I'm actually
anxious to know what the round four
pairings are tell our audience what they
can expect for this parent right let's
take a look our little Gary kasparo will
be playing Livonia fantastic talk about
a matchup between their leaders that's
going to be a marquee matchup and
Jeffrey Zhang is playing Ray Robson
right Fabiano caruana facing Hikaru
Nakamura two great Rivals of American
chess that will certainly be a match
that we watch carefully Sam Savion who's
having a great tournament playing Wesley
so and Sam Shanklin playing Lanier
Dominguez the players are fighting hard
what are they fighting for they're
fighting for a handsome prize fun
there's total of hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in prizes first place
winner is going to win 37 and 500 very
nice second place 25
000 third twenty thousand and
everybody's guaranteed at least a
minimum of 7 500 even if you finish the
last as we get ready for the big reveal
uh coming up uh quite shortly as we see
the players at the World Chess Hall of
Fame they're actually just across the
street from us from St Louis Chesapeake
everyone's loving the t-shirts that yes
specifically designed for this event
exactly the players get swag for these
events and that'd be certainly sporting
is a t-shirt there's as we see the
players getting ready I have to say it's
a really good t-shirt I mean those
Scholars really yeah
nice nice
uh well again for me it's a Kind of a
Funny event in the sense that of the 10
players nine American one Gary kisbarov
it really looks like Gary versus America
and Gary's winning against America
and the Americans are going to have to
gather around and you know rally uh to
the cause here Christian think about
Gary 60 years young oh just an
incredible Pace I mean uh he was
confident yesterday and you could feel
it and you could feel it from the first
game you know that first game is so
important right yes what is your pace
for the day and we could feel that after
he dismantled Wesley so in what it was
not an easy game let's not forget out of
the opening he was spending a lot of
time he was trying to figure out his way
out and he did with very precise moves
and this is something that I follow
throughout the day he was playing very
precise chess he was taking his time and
sure maybe getting to those last few
minutes but even in those last few
minutes he was still defending precisely
and we've seen that in the game against
Chicago Nakamura a really good Play by
Gary if he can maintain that form I mean
he's going to be formidable in this one
right as we hear in the background there
the Arbiter is announcing
um they're getting ready for the
um the first position exactly exactly
and here it comes
and randomize the uh back rank at first
rank positions and we'll be showing it
to you shortly as we get it here it
comes shake them up
all right
this feels to me like it's a bishop
problem the bishop on B1 the bishop on
E1 the knights are okay the knight's
gonna find the queen is okay actually I
like what you said you don't have to
Castle for a long while and the only
weak pawns that I'm seeing are um E2
in G2 right so Knight E6 to D4 takes E2
Checkmate but the thing is that Conor E2
can easily be defended most likely and
will be defended with the Knight coming
to G3 or G6 right and after what you
said yesterday about Bishop on B1 I kind
of like it there because after C4 and
Quincy too hello it's a nice little
Checkmate that's right but how are you
going to solve the bishop on E1 You're
Gonna Go D4 you have to go D4 right but
then you're gonna put it where after
deep so D4 C4 and C3 so you're gonna go
c4d4 Queen C2 Bishop C3 let's forget
about the Knight on A1 right right right
you won't need that per Checkmate as uh
the players uh as we saw in day one they
uh tend to gather flock together and uh
favorites uh join and ikaru I noticed
that Gary is seem to enjoy each other's
trade you know they could join there
it's uh playing Fabi in this round or
Lanier I think these three players
already played each other so they can
analyze together
hey Carlos playing against Fabi right I
don't think Wesley played Hikaru right
right but they both played Gary so yes
yes and Wesley is going to be playing in
Sam Savion who's actually tied for
second place with Lavon I saw C3 was on
the board on their analysis board and
then Gary played Knight B3 really early
right for me I like solving my problem
piece first so for me an opening move
like C4 and D4 and here this is
interesting so one is D4 so D4 C5
DTX C5 it's it's kind of like uh it's
candy right like what but the Queen's
attacked with a knight right
oh this is raised positions
all by himself getting his Queen kicked
around yeah
how do you say
um
I actually heard from him yesterday that
when he played live on and he spent like
six minutes on the first move it's
because when he analyzed the starting
position he looked at it from Whiteside
forgot that he had the black pieces
so success
has many parents
failure is an orphan
well poor Ray all by himself I mean
that's that's not fair where where is
Sam shangland where is uh
you you were telling a nice story
yesterday's broadcast Christian about
ali Reza who was all always sitting
alone but he wasn't even trying like he
wasn't actually trying to analyze he was
just looking at the position and maybe
analyzing in his head right right just
for the simple fact that he perhaps
wanted to preserve some uh intuitive
feel about the position not go too much
and too detailed into the analysis and
actually I noticed uh Livonia is playing
Gary and Gary's with black but Gary was
analyzing from the white side so
yeah right I hope he knows he's playing
with that I hope so too now in
yesterday's round three position
Gary complained that the the that the
position itself had a great Advantage he
felt for white and I agreed with him
that was the one where you get to play
H4 and kick a knight on G6 this one
feels to me more balanced how about you
it does look more balanced but I guess
we will see after the opening
it will be a lot more uh clear because
the players are having trouble with the
black pieces because we thought it was
equal yesterday and then realized
because most of the black players got a
worse position right out of the opening
exactly as we can see Wesley Wesley is
really finding some interesting ideas
with the black pieces and especially
that Wesley gamble they have the wrestle
again uh he I'm just looking at my board
here for a second uh one of the things I
thought was funny about none of the
players seem to be looking at it
is I like the move d4 and they were
looking at D5 right now they were
looking at C4 as well as Knight E3 which
I find peculiar like I said I I tend to
want to
take care of my problem piece I like the
move Bishop before with the tempo I was
pointing out that it's this Pawn on E7
as well as the pawn on G7 that are the
pawn weaknesses they're only being
defended uh in the case of G7 by the
king in case of E7 by nothing now this
could and likely would uh precipitate
the move at Knight G6 and then exactly
in this moment you could start to look
at what I would call a very forcing
sequence that might begin with a move H
to H4 so for me G4 here is that Knight
F4 threads okay just a second because I
do nothing because you do have 93 pound
sacrifice yeah I'll take the Wesley
Gamble it under my wing here I I'll see
if I can't get you know kind of trap
your queen here like somehow and oh you
don't I can't I don't have 93. I was
going to play C4 and Bishop to D3 as a
as a try in terms of traffic and I guess
that's a good question right are you
going to leave The Rook on H1 and
because you know most likely that Knight
is going to land on G6 you were
Connecting the Dots here yes you said
that there's going to be some problems
with the E2 and E7 Pawn correct right
right that's probably going to force
white or black to defend that with the
Knight and then you have the option as
either white or black to leave The Rook
on the Square that we see it right now
or to Castle because you can Castle in
one move you're only one move away from
castling Knight G3 and then Castle is
already ready so you have that option I
guess this is one of their dilemmas
right now they're trying to figure out
and trying to analyze it's like you can
cast a long move too right you just get
your uh but each floor is so much more
interesting yeah much more interesting
so yeah and here uh it's this very very
early window in Fisher random where
especially in the first half dozen dozen
moves that uh some very peculiar tactics
a very unusual patterns can occur later
in the game the players are neutralizing
the positions they're getting to
familiar territories like isolated Queen
pawns and stuff like that I love the
game yesterday
between Wesley so and Fabiano where
Wesley's Rook went from D4 to H4 and
attacked the pawn on H7 within the first
half dozen moves you've never seen
not even close yeah that was all you
need that was all you knew everything
nobody I I would go over there just to
give them
to comfort him you know like I know Ray
you lost two games yesterday nobody
wants to talk to you no one wants to be
friends I think I actually like working
alone so I would purposely go on a table
it's in the corner and work on and then
when I when a nice guy like me comes
over and said how you doing you're like
leave me alone
trying to figure out what to play go
away
well the thing is when he's training
with himself what oh 92 Checkmate see
he's coming up
so if Rey was does this play against
himself who would win
and this is something that I think he
struggled with yesterday recognizing
patterns and this is what we're seeing
him try to practice right now you saw
that Queen day C5 that B5 there is no
way you can get away without the queen
on C4 defending that pawn on E3 so he's
just recognizing patterns right now
right and reason why uh we can all play
fast in time trouble is because we can
recognize patterns but in these
positions you can then you really need
to use more time and that's why we see
not just Gary and Rey but even fappy and
Wesley going into time troubles somebody
told Jeffrey to go to Rey yeah
oh he heard me it's going
Jeffrey very very quiet in these
analysis sessions
absorbs it all you know and two sims the
two Sams
I noticed they're all trying to develop
their nights really early which is again
for me peculiar because it seems to me
like the knights you you know where
they're going to go they're going to go
to G3 and B3 the bishop on B1 I can
understand why you don't necessarily
want to develop it it's somehow very
developed but the bishop on E1 I just
feel it is a is a bad influencer
you want to do something with that
Bishop on E1 and find a proper Square
maybe they've decided that Bishop's not
going to be great anyways and let's just
leave it only one
try to develop rest of their businesses
that's that's that's all fair for sure
and again
they quickly exchanged the queens and
then Bishop only one is fine yeah the
now it'll pop out to C3 and it'll look
just just handsome on the that diagonal
I am still concerned that Garrison
always in with the white pieces because
he's playing with black
still one of the Great Moments in these
uh Fisher 9lx uh tournaments was when
Gary and Peter Fiddler were analyzing
together and Peter came up with the
wrong position they had been analyzing
it for 15 minutes
Gary was let's say less than pleased I
can imagine less than please I'm not
worried about Gary analyzing with white
because both Gary and Hikaru are playing
Black so somebody had somebody had to
sit under to take the white side ah now
they're looking at Bishop B finally D4
D5 let's see what they just put on the
board d4d closer to the truth they
eliminated all the bad options exactly
exactly Bishop came to B4 as we saw and
then they made a move actually I was a
little bit uh funny about E7 E6 inviting
the bishop to code
no you don't it's like it would be but
they did play E6 they didn't go Knight
Jesus this was force bishop f8 and then
there's no more Castle because King f8
interesting so something like this even
at the cost of the two Bishops gives up
uh all castling privilege privileges
will stop the king cannot go kingside or
queen side and now you might go see
three so G6 King G7 right away because
he will always have Queen H6 exactly no
that would be uh a frightening
introduction and The Rook on D7 really
does look remember I was telling you
yesterday that I I find in Fisher random
the clumsy Rook that uh you're gonna let
me do an unveil that Rook on D7 looks
several what what is what is Ray doing I
thought it's really having some fun with
uh with himself yeah yeah no Ray is
really enjoying it I mean at the board
he's a stoic quiet like when he's
analyzing the the NRA is exposed look at
this
he's more animated than Gary I mean
whatever is in his coffee
once you're just thinking about Chess
you forget where you are what's going on
this is a happy example let's move 20
right come on get back to the initial
position he's just a happy camper look
at the night on F4 ready go Knight takes
E2 smothered Checkmate imagine just put
in the wrong position right now when
you're setting up analysis
and getting the position wrong that
could easily happen very easily
easily
all right C4 C5 D4 take take it seems
like I'm not sure why he expects C4 and
this is something that you were
mentioning uh Nazi as well he was
expecting a different move he only
analyzed one of uh the moves I believe
C4 with white never considered D4 in
yesterday's game and that's why he had
problems exactly exactly you need to
look at uh different because the first
move openings whether it be E4 D4 lead
to entirely different positions I wanted
to ask you about this opening position
Christian one of the things that the
players like is is is going for the
binds what do you think about D4
C5 D5 trying to set up one of those
opening Vines and by what what do you
think you mean what does the engine
think yeah or you or the engine yeah
deforce C5 D5 B5 okay kind of like a
benoni yeah benko yeah okay H4 seems to
be the best response H4 H4 very
interesting or maybe E4 okay H4 E4 black
was playing H5 I have a feeling
and then let's say Night comes out to B6
right to Basics yeah okay because you
know that night is going to be now it
does seem like H4 is wow how come H4 is
getting so much love and attention move
three were out sorry move forward we're
out of uh just nine elex Theory right
good to know yes yesterday I think we
had the zoo
they were following some game from the
zoo I was like what
nice okay well we are getting ready as a
hearty handshakes
uh the players are taking their seats
for round four
nlx and we've got a huge game between
Lavon aronian and Gary Kasparov yeah
we're currently in first and second
place correct and uh Gary made reference
to last year's game where he lost as he
described it an equal ending maybe he
was slightly better but he lost terribly
so he's obviously uh still suffering
about he wants his revenge well yes from
a year ago
and you see a very intense scary now it
is so intimidating yes I remember I
remember now Gary would come to the
board and he'd take off his watch at the
start of the game and he put it down and
then you know eats flex and put his
hands cup his ears and Away you went
in the past we had the analog clocks not
the dgging he just pound the button bam
livon shares your opinion that you
should develop the bishop first right D4
opening now it seemed that uh Gary was a
little bit unsure they were looking at
D4 but they were looking also at C6 at
D5 and C5 and there were it it seemed
like he was a little bit unsure uh
finally you know 15 minutes is not
enough time to
go on Lavon
what is happening E6 now here's the
question I love this idea of Bishop E7
forcing The Rook to be misplaced the
Rook on D7 makes a terrible impression
and then to follow up with your idea of
just giving Bishop takes f8 so here's
the point you go after the move E6
you drop your Bishop in this is a very
unusual pattern you will not see this
whatsoever in modern chess Rook to D7
Bishop takes EFA King takes f8 no
castling for black on either side and
this Rook is making a woeful impression
unfortunately we're not going to see
this most likely because Levon played
Knight G3 it is it's still a possibility
depending on Gary's move exactly okay
technical question please
how do you Castle in this position do
you tap the king and then move the Rook
or do you touch the rook and just like
uh if you're white if you're white yes
it doesn't matter you have to tap the
king first yes you have to tap the king
and put the king
uh on the G1 school
but it's a good question now by the way
uh because the bishop is on B4
the king when it castles cannot move
through check but in this case the king
is not moving through check so it would
be illegal move to Castle
that's my question for the Arbiter would
it be a league I'd be blundering in
exchange there's no question about that
but I think it is legal because the king
is not Crossing it
well there's one for that there's one
for our uh arbitrary our crack arbiting
team by the way B7 B6 I think that's a
terrible move yeah I think that's a
terrible move because it really is
encouraging you now if I go Bishop E7
Rook D7 Bishop f8 I get the same
position
with the move B7 B6 I I get to include
Knight G3 a useful move you get to
include a move B6 which actually robs
you of the knights best Square I agree
you're preparing C5 but I don't like the
move B6 how does the computer business
is fine no question okay could you ask
me about that move actually if you go
Bishop E7 Rook D7 Bishop f8 what's the
computer's conclusion about this
position C3 close to equality still so
for example I think you have to go E4 or
C3 C4 perhaps right C3 you want to go C3
already gives black the advantage of
their C5 you're allowing black to get
the initiative because this rook in fact
is not so badly placed after the move
Rook to C7 so if you don't mind just uh
Knight B3 right now right okay I I want
to play C4 C4 okay Knight D2 maybe even
take you know what this looks much more
humanly just to take and then Knight
takes assume you're taking right yeah
I wanted to go Knight C6
yeah
wait a minute
apparently age five seems to be the best
move it's kind of crazy look I'll give
it to you it looks kind of crazy
wow for a second I thought that the
night was on B8 and I was happy with my
position but with an iPhone 8 indeed
this move B6 seems a little bit out of
place by the way he's following almost
and hikaru's game we have this position
with H4 and H5 because Hikaru also
played B6 just as Gary and he kind of
analyzed okay the the D4 Bishop B4 got
two thumbs up by uh Fabi and Lavon and
then this H5 H4 inclusion everybody
likes B6 so we are seeing the best
players in the world gravitate
how would I even describe that they're
they're coming up with the same ideas
and by the way in the Lavon game which I
thought was kind of funny he played
Bishop back to eat
oh he did go Bishop to E7 yes and then
he voluntarily came back with Bishop A3
he just wanted to tickle The Rook into
uh this position let's just take a look
around the board let's jump to uh Sam
sevion just one second please because it
does seem like Sam shankland ah actually
no you're right Sam sebian versus Wesley
so that one is hot right now Wesley is
in trouble all right Wesley is in
trouble
after this move D5 right yes indeed you
can take on D5 okay in fact it's not
even that difficult to spot it follow it
up with D4 and that puts tremendous
pressure on Black's position if you go
C4 I can continue with E4 your pieces
are just dislodged right that Rook is
not supposed to be on D5 so early in the
cars in the game right yeah it's not
looking good I have to say is his idea
maybe after he takes D5 to play Knight
F4 uh another sacrifice I don't think so
well well it is got but I can think on
C5 right oh yeah I've got the I've got
the Checkmate covered yeah now the night
is already done I do I take on C5 I'm
two pawns up sure you'll take one back
but okay it wouldn't work here no the
Wesley Camp it's uh not not on fire
um Rook takes defa that is a very
peculiar thing because D d2d4 is is it
kind of pretends to be uh played right
by the way uh Ray is also in huge huge
trouble right now well you highlighted
it at the top of the show that losing in
a dozen moves is not uh
Knight G6 H4 E5
now I saw that Ray had positions where
he was looking at Queen G4 and Knight F4
Knight takes E2 so this move E7 E5 looks
like prep but why is it bad a Christian
well he played C3 by the way Jeffrey
which is not the correct move in the
position too slow you had to go H5 just
continue Knight F4 makes a lot of sense
you have to defend the pawn onito
somehow either Queen to E3 or Knight to
G3 but it does seem like the queen is
nicely placed on C1 for the moment
Knight to G3 no no nitrog3 is in fact
the best move
Knight to G3 I mean I saw Rey looking at
these types of ideas where he could play
for Queen takes G3 and Knight takes E2
sure but even in this position perhaps I
can go Queen to E3 right Queen to E3
um either that or I can just take on E5
and invite this trade of the knights
I just say that I have a better position
for the simple fact that I would assume
you're going to take right I want to
take like this the pawn structure it's
not great for white but do we have an
extra Pawn no we don't know I I clipped
the pawn on the way to C1
interesting to be more precise uh let me
just jump uh to the game of Sam Savion
and Wesley so because he did capture and
he did follow your advice with D4 and
then finally the one game that I'm
missing is Sam shankland and Lanier
Dominguez let's see how they these two
uh greats
uh clay by the way did Sam move his King
oh you see that yes he did yes he did he
said uh uh I don't want to see the night
drop on E2 that was
I didn't consider that he could defend
E2 with your kid that was a surprise
move uh I think 93 was a bad move but
there's a big difference on the clocks
but this is what we discussed right I
mean there was always that question are
you going to leave The Rook on H1 or are
you going to put the Rook on F1 in
Castle uh traditionally
he decides to just put the Rook on H1
King on F1 is not badly placed by any
means that that Knight on A4 is going to
get uh kicked back either via G3 maybe
after the move the knight from E3 lands
on G4 and the Knight on F4 is going to
get kicked back so it's an interesting
setup it seems like Sam is confident in
the setup and perhaps he analyzed it
with his partner Sam Sevilla all right
we'll keep an eye on this as we'll go
back to the Gary Kasparov show as he
takes on the whole of America here H4 H5
included The Rook makes a very strange
impression why would you put your Rook
there well it was induced to go there
there was a bishop coming to E7 and
that's it give me your take on this
position I I'm still not sure myself how
do you like it after black plays C5 yep
something black has that many problems
but back in my head I'm still thinking
that black can play Knight to six yeah
and that no no no that's not gonna
happen Okay so let's imagine that you
play C5 and Gary's taking his time and
by the way that is a
I would say I'll put it like this I
think they just played the move C5 so
the players are catching up with our
analysis board which is on the right
side of your screen so the move C5 now
personally I would be
while fearful is strong I'd be wary the
move Bishop takes G3 but let me try to
guess lavon's idea which he's put his
Bishop on A3 he wants an open diagonal
so I'm going to guess levon's plan was
to play Knight B3 and if you'd like to
take and either play C4 or take
would you would you take on G3 give up
the two Bishops maybe not yet because
what's the rush right it's not like I'm
I'm running to go F5 or E4 or somewhere
else so uh what Would You Do To Handle
by the way to constantly five right away
he did yes so okay so it could only mean
that his intentional trying to follow up
with C4 maybe either that or C4 first
yeah
C4 to try to
keep that as a Target here should black
push D4 take on C4 or just playing okay
well we can't play Knight B6 because C5
I'm always looking for those types of
binding buying positions but in this
case I think the weakness of C5 is too
strong too strong right
an overreach
um oh my goodness what here is
completely busted it seems like Lanier
is completely busted and in fact he's
going to lose what has happened when we
left it we saw the move King F1 D4 B6
and then G3 get out of Dodge
night drop back Bishop E4 uh-oh uh
Spidey senses tingling here what are we
doing with this Knight on A8 to go
Knight C7
captured on D well if you go Knight C7
right away I guess he was afraid that
we'll capture okay and after take take
now 97 seems like the only move
right
Okay Christian why is he completely he
played Knight C7 this is plus six right
now what
Sam finds the move what was the weakness
in the position E7 from the beginning no
five nights
at Five let's do it this way yes so we
can expose oh my word exactly and if you
go king of Faith now I have Queen G5 wow
or Bishop Bishop to B4 it's over oh
Knight and five plus seven how many
moves eight moves eight moves
wow well Lanier is going to be in for a
shot oh my goodness Lanier is going to
be in for a shock when somebody tells
him you know you were you were minus
eight after eight and you know
Sam probably sees it because whenever
Lanier played Knight to C7 Sam for a
second and a half he looked away from
the board that means I did not expect
this move what am I missing because he
knows that Knight F5 is available in the
position he's calculating it right now
if he plays it Lanier is pretty much
possible so question Christian neither
five I take and on Knight R5 can I move
the queen to A6 you can but Queen to G5
is once again a problem
you have the Knight on H5 under attack
you have the Rook on the eight and you
cannot I thought I could play G6 here
but rook's hanging on there okay but to
continue the thought for a moment uh F6
Knight H6
these six Rook takes D6 oh you can take
my queen no problem this is too pretty
oh my goodness wow that Checkmate but
double check double check mate double
check that's a visual uh you put that on
on your upcoming best seller Fisher
random hits the best hits of fish are
random chess by and by the way my key on
F1 is perfectly safe yes no checks not
at all
that is true so we're looking at Knight
F5 and we're cheering Sam to find does
it matter which nights no I no the
reason I chose the night on E3 by the
way was just because I was thinking that
open up the Queen open up the queen and
that was why I chose this but probably
the D4 Knight is just as good
yeah and he just just double checking
his calculations okay back to these are
some of those patterns that you just
simply are not aware of not accustomed
to and this is exactly because linear
doesn't miss this type of thing of
course right of course in a normal game
of chess but the position is so complex
and so weird right right you just simply
don't see these patterns oh yeah there's
a check on B4 from that bishopone E1 no
that I didn't place it there it was just
there at the beginning of uh the game
it's all so weird right but both of
yourselves were trying to play Knight on
A8 to C6
because like
can't do it I gotta go back to our
Marquee matchup between Lavon and Gary
check please Bobby's game real quick
let's do it long which was unexpected
wow we have openc file that was a long
uh and by the way we did have this
inclusion of Bishop E7 on another board
as well this uh Fabi did
and this is where you're right castles
the King on G1 want it was safe on G1
let's move it to more open file to open
it well it's just that the inclusion of
H4 and H5 makes the king size a little
bit worried that Black's Rook can
actually jump to C7 very quickly okay
and actually cause some trouble for
white
yeah it's something you definitely want
to keep track of but now on the other
hand I think Fabi is good because Fabi
is looking to trade and he's saying the
action might be the open default
no
both Players missed it but by the way
the move Bishop B4
I mean once you see the bishop before
no more good but it's not the same no
why I can defend E7 now I can take it I
can go Queen E6 right
what an opportunity
oh no oh no that was hold on is this
true or because again I I so wanted to
continue no but here correct Queen
G5 Queen takes this is hanging with the
mates exactly it's not the same it's not
the same
ouch I missed a golden
um D6 he thought that he could take time
with his attack
wait a minute though because again if
you're in Sam
oh by the way he's maybe he's missed
another tactic if his intention was to
play Knight C6 uh again a tactic that
you're not used to seeing both Bishops
are hanging after Knight C6 Bishop takes
great Bishop F3 makes sense Knight went
to F6 makes sense I think he's just
playing positionally he does have a
better position still without question
there's no quick beautiful well no quick
view you know this is one of those
missed opportunities that you're glad
you don't see it after you make your
move because then you just think why did
I miss that it would be better for Sam
if he doesn't see that until the
tournament's over correct oh now this is
thinking outside of the box you've
already played G3 now G4 what do you
think of those apples Christian I'm not
sure about that I mean it's it looks
good and Samsung still has a pretty
decent Advantage but it's not even
comparable to what he had before at the
same time I'm looking also at the clock
uh he's ahead on the clock and he has
the initiative he has more space in the
center and on the king side I have to
give it to Sam still big favorite to
take down Lanier in this one well hold
on just a second if I do continue with
the move Knight A6 for just a moment
okay then I'm attacking the bishop go
back to C3 ah that was my question
because I'm starting to think like a
sicilian player like I I wanted to make
uh room for a few of my pieces right H6
and now Rook G1 the thing is
B4 and on the a3fa diagonal doesn't have
a job anymore so I'm dropping it back to
C3 I know something is going to happen
along the G file right that G7 Pawn is
going to be tender yep
makes sense to me uh sorry I did want to
get back to what I thought or think is
going to be our Marquee matchup of this
round for Lavon aronium versus Gary
Kasparov
Gary is way behind down the clock now
and the position is not very inspiring
so he did take on G3 as we were
considering right but he's
after eight moves
the problem for him
14 and 15 minutes for Lavon just six and
a half for Gary takes on C7 Rook C7 at
the moment too it was a sacrifice of
course but
um what was the point of the sacrifice
I'm not 100 sure so I'm a pawn grubber
let me be this put a lot of pressure on
the C file okay yeah and
so now nobody can Castle right so uh one
day I'm gonna play C3
White Castle yeah yeah that is true I'm
gonna one day I'm just gonna play C3 and
I'm gonna ask where's the compensation
um well it double pawns on G file is
still
not great I agree with that because
Black Knight needs to move from B6 to G4
very quickly but you know what that
means that means that my king is going
to be extremely safe white skin
well placed on H2 I do like what uh what
Nasi was saying that anchored the Knight
on G4 just to make sure correct the king
isn't super safe to let you I don't have
to let you why not maybe so let's go
Knight C4 right yeah I went E3 how do
you stop you're saying that
Queen F4 is not well B2 you really want
to take that pawn Yes actually sorry
sorry who are you talking about
I'm offended this is disrespectful it
truly is yes are you going to take that
pie I forgot who I'm talking
uh good morning St Louis
okay we'll keep an eye on this one uh
none of this is forced by the way I mean
it's just that this move uh Rook C7 is
provocative maybe we'll just fall back
on what the intention uh Lavon intended
all the while to play C4 and Knight B3
maybe he's thinking I I I'm I'm happier
to
um
to to have an open D file like if I've
provoked the move captures you know I'm
happy to have a an active Rook than I am
to be a pawn up uh interesting and one
game that's going really really badly
for black players it's uh Sam Savion
against Wesley so oh well let's jump to
that oh now we do have a mind we were
always talking about should I get in D5
like as early as move two right so when
we left it we left it here Bishop A4
E4 it looks like uh Sam is the one with
a very promising initiative Knight F5 D5
this looks terrible I mean just flat out
terrible uh there's just so many
problems in Black's position no question
about it and Rook C1 is a good move but
he hadn't even better blow in this
position and that is the move Queen to
C3 Bishop C3 Queen to C3 Quinto C3 now
it's very difficult to defend that G7
Pawn without giving up material oh boy
if you go Queen E5 I just simply pick up
the C5 Pawn that's going to be a pawn up
and I still have Bishop to C3 coming
that looks terrible so I have to play F6
yes but you cannot that is so ugly but
you can't that's the problem because
after F6 I go D6 and guess what queen C4
is coming and that bishopone A4 is
hanging yes it is these are the type
once again it's the geometry yeah that
doesn't look remotely close to anything
we see each other no I know uh Rook C1
not a bad move but as you say maybe
another one of those missed moments as
we saw earlier uh look Wesley's still in
trouble Wesley still in trouble Wesley
is still definitely in trouble
what I wanted to ask isn't the
Intermezzo give me a Tempo against your
queen I always have a b I'm not
necessarily obliged to only play Queen
takes P3 I like it this is true if you
try to keep contact with the Rook on C5
with Queen B6 yeah guess what Bishop A5
oh
ouch
well that and that that clears the
cobwebs all together this is a terrible
position for Wesley I think he misses
65. he's in terrible trouble jumping to
Jeffrey Zhang and uh Ray Ray Robson when
we left it I like his Pawn chain
yeah it suddenly worked out just we're
seeing another one of those Bishop takes
G6 Bishop takes G3 uh positions as check
this move out E5 E4 and I I
wholeheartedly agree that's a an
impressive Pawn chain and a very active
lurking Bishop there on B8 once this
Knight gets back over here to
civilization uh I'm I'm all for big
Advantage black Ray positionally black
is just doing much better agreed agreed
wholeheartedly uh jumping to a linear
and Sam shankler well I'm not going to
say it's an open Sicilian because you
don't usually see the Bishops on on V8
and E8 in open Sicilians but it it has
Echoes actually you kind of there
there's only one
and Bishop D7 Bishop ba to defend uh the
king side
but I agree it's a bit of a stretch yeah
if you put the bishop on B7 and the
bishop on C7 we it sure does look like a
hedgehog but not a good one not a good
Hedgehog and by the way if you take it
one move back instead of Queen to C2 yes
Knight C5
Knight F5 was again a huge blow in the
position and in fact just win second
time in this game second time missed it
once again wait here it's harder to
understand why I agree I agree from a
human perspective this one is much more
difficult but you start seeing Knight to
E7 also Knight takes G7 comes and now we
understand why that pawn is nicely
placed on G4 right ready to go to G5
ready to set up the pin this is looking
really ugly and you cannot take by the
way on G5 because Queen takes G5 comes
as well
yes this is pretty much over at this
point
at this point also in this particular
case too I've got H1 covered but I am
eyeballing Queen takes G5 and G1 is a
potential attack this looks terrible it
is it is it looks terrible escaped again
from an immediate death
somewhere Michael tall is crying he said
didn't I leave any kind of a legacy
behind me tell us here
like didn't anybody study my games after
the move Queen C2 by the way Lanier says
you know what
I'm terrified of this bishop let me let
me try to get rid of it he's played the
move Knight A4 with good reasons again
I'm going to go back to E1
yes starting position yes
maybe bishop back to E1 the question
played B3 and come right back and yeah
re-recharge uh again our two Marquee
matchup games let's just check in on
fobby and ikaru fortunately things have
died down a lot and we can basically say
regular chest regular ending although it
is unusual to see a bishop on F3 with
bonds
we promoted upon to a bishop and then
brought it back to F3 where it would be
nicely protected uh unusual ending but
again Lavon and Gary let's just catch up
on what those two have been up to figure
his clock which is six minutes oh is
that six minutes
catching up two he's down to eight
minutes castles Knight B6
still pretty early in the game okay that
move by Gary F7 F6 that was a very uh I
was gonna say surprise move for me best
move in the position he wants to play E5
he wants to play Bishop G6 and
essentially that Rook on C7 is doing
pretty good work at the moment hook to
seven wasn't so bad after all it turned
out okay that is for sure but here comes
Knight B3 and there's always ideas of
sacrificing oh no I take that back
pardon me and I take C5 in a double
attack uh with Rook d8 is going to be
met by Queen take C5 check right
apologies for that but uh Knight B3 on
the board so with F6 Gary's playing to
planning to play E5 right I thought it
was Bishop G6 but okay let's have a look
see E5 and let's say the queen drops
back yeah
yes a real real problem but
96 Bishop F5 right that was not happy
with that yeah
I I always say uh strong chess players
uh Grandmasters just hate being in pins
I thought Gary was playing for Bishop G6
because he played it because of the
advantage whenever your opponent has the
two Bishops one of the things I really
enjoy is taking away that Advantage from
my opponent so you would hate to move E4
here
yeah
it's not a good move but you know what
you know in order to preserve the two
Bishops I would certainly consider it uh
before makes my Bishop on B1 actually
bad exactly exactly and also allows
Knight C4 so you can still get rid of my
idea uh good point and uh what has got
your eye Christian I was watching this
one with you guys and I have to say the
last few moves Gary is catching up not
only on time but in the position as well
he was in slight danger after the
opening phase but right now the engine
is saying he equalized at least and I
have to say from a humorous perspective
it just feels easier to play with black
he has a healthier at least on the king
Side Pawn structure you have that Knight
coming to E5 you have that Bishop on A3
that is not doing that much at least not
up to this point if you don't manage to
create enough pressure on that C5 pawn
and whenever you do I will just simply
push C4 so I'm looking at all these
details and I'm starting to like Gary's
position once again okay if I can just
play devil's advocate for a moment and
uh well I was going I was definitely not
going to develop my opponent's pieces
for him I was looking at both Queen F2
immediately putting pressure on C5 the
much more obvious to my eye whenever you
have an open file with your Rook sitting
on the open file what's the purpose of
an open file to penetrate on the open
file especially the seventh and eighth
ranks so if I could post up and invite
Bishop takes Rook takes and what am I
trying to do I'm trying to double uh he
did not play any of this by the way
Lavon captured on G6 played Knight
captures you and queen to F2 is Gary
ready for a sacrifice yeah like in 95 94
idea still very very much so uh that
would be on my agenda but another one
I'm really looking at is Knight C4
that's another one Bishop takes C5 and
let me see perhaps you can even take on
them can you take on B2 Knight E5 Knight
takes B2 uh I like I I desperately want
to post the night up on G4 for all of
those obvious reasons that we had to
deal with the king
um jump in Christian oh that's the way
to that's one of the ways to uh connect
the dots into position Knight C4 Bishop
takes C5 and maybe just simply Knight G5
Kerry is entering serious time trouble
three minutes three and a half minutes
look if you manage to get King F7 Rook
to d8 exchange that Rook on the D file I
can castle with black I don't have to
play King F7 but I can't hold the Rook
on f8 because
oh you're right I apologize
it's not even legal right that was a
question that was our question you
didn't join the question I was saying
can you make it on the analysis board
and see if it's legal all right okay
that's a good question here we go yes
it's legal it's legal yes you can yes
you you can castle and put the Rook on
pre but you can't put the King on free
nice okay uh I'm just going to refresh
the board for a second and queen F2 is
on the board and Gary is under 35. yes
he does yes he sacrificed Gary's
trusting his instincts he said the hand
still knows where the pieces belongs
she's exactly what his point was
yesterday but three minutes his downfall
in last year's competition as well he
didn't trust his son he said this is
something that I uh will pay close
attention to in this year's Edition and
he does it
and let's just check in with Sam
Shanklin versus Lanier Dominguez because
we think that Sam had a huge advantage
and that still appears to be the case by
the way I mean just looking at this
Checkmate ideas oh seven out of six and
just Queen D1 Queen H1 the move order
matters Let's Do It Let's Do It Rip
takes check and maybe start with Queen
D1 Queen D1 you're all right before
Knight F6 so even before yeah well he
started I think with Queen C1 uh leaving
his Knight on D4 on pre uh is Sam
Shanklin he plays the move Queen C1
which defends the night deep pardon me
defends the pawn on G5 but what he's
really aspiring for is to sacrifice The
Rook follow it up with Queen H1 and
knight uh F6 that looks deadly yes I
think we should probably go to uh
Shanklin versus Lanier because yes we
are
guess who's watching
this happens once per show yes that's
true that's true he's completely busted
completely completely busted I think he
missed his last move Queen to C1 yes
look at the elegancy of this move right
you cannot touch this Knight it's a
beautiful Harmony no question they take
Queen to H1 and you get checkmated right
and as pretty as this win is going to be
he will still be disappointed that he
misses this Knight at five earlier uh
Knight E6 uh Sam enjoying a nice okay
reaching reaching that's a Checkmate
Rider so come on Sam your inner your
inner Nike just do it
he's done it yes take him alone faster
or stronger Rook takes H7 okay whatever
I got I gotta take to F take on D4 and
maybe run to f8 E7 I'm not running
you're not running anywhere I think I
think his threat is actually just
so let's say I take on D4 he takes D4
with the pawn just in case nice can help
Knight can stop defend G7 okay so I in
that case I guess I will but I'm not
running far you have 95. night I was
about just at the same time I was
playing Bishop the diva you were telling
me I had Knight D5 I think 95 is also
strong yes
and uh by the way as things heat up in
this round four Ray Robson as usual down
to his increment we should stay with
this because it's about to be over okay
all right and by the way no takes on D4
but King takes Sam reaching his first
queen queen H1 as Advent to calculate so
many force and moves Knight F6 well I
can just simply go Queen H6 right
ah maybe you have Knight F4 Knight H5 no
but even then I have Knight F6 which
leads to Checkmate but Knight F6 looks
good Queen h8 Knight D5 check oh no
sorry what would you like but where's
the Checkmate Knight F6 Knight F6 King
h8 King f8
yeah let's get on our running shoes
We're jogging for the hills
and King D7 we're still running of
course step six uh we may be running but
maybe not very far Bishop on F3 I hear
you uh with it
27 and Knight B6
that's nice
thank you
oh boy nice okay that's a very forcing
sequence has like five pieces around the
beginning
Queen F6 don't I have Knight F4 though
so here here here here here
Knight F4 what are you a party pooper
night F4 I'm sure I'm not I mean the
position looks completely busted
nonetheless but I wish quina for a queen
of four
nice are we gonna see Queen h8 are we
gonna see Knight
d54 guys
he's reaching
yeah
it must be still winning but it's not oh
there he goes yeah
I think he spotted queen of six
you think so yeah okay well here we go
he's done it oh if he goes for that
Knight F4 Queen F4 that would be sweet
that would be and queen takes F4 yes no
oh no he's reaching for the night that's
completely winning us oh you cannot take
with the pawn because we can't take with
the pawn because I think um
unfortunately that just wins on the spot
because King takes unfortunately yeah I
mean because Queen F6 Queen takes F4 was
just so pretty
uh this looks over this looks completely
busted we think linear is gonna
when that I'm going to move over to the
Ray Robson game because
raised down to two seconds and
well
Wiggins three and a half minutes not fun
uh Jeffrey position
okay we've been thinking about the
knights on G4 and G5 and a number they
constructure it just is begging for the
night to go there exactly it's like the
ideal Square Rook f8 Ray down to eight
seconds but I think his positions
somehow there's enough cohesion that
it's not
clear to me that uh Jeffrey has any kind
of a knockout I mean it's it's the clock
is the issue but probably close to equal
well wait a minute isn't black a pawn up
oh that's all I Do by the way 90 by the
way I I have a brother in arms Alex here
malinski he said to me uh I he said he
said to me that 90 of the time he's
calculating the pawns uh and by the way
we did we did get uh a linear did resign
that position that we left salmon as our
congratulations to Sam Shanklin uh jump
in Christian uh I don't see any
Knockouts for Jeffrey Zhang here
position is equal is equal the position
is actually equal yeah yeah so all the
advantages on the clock yes correct yes
that's still pretty significant and
Bishop takes Rook takes and maybe not
only on the clock but also from a
practical perspective forget about the
objective eval of the position from a
practical perspective with those
centralized pawns like that The Rook F7
allowing Knight G5 later on King G2 or
King E3 I don't know I don't like that
square for The Rook I think he's gonna
move his Rook right away
rookie is seven maybe yes I agree with
you on that but okay yeah it does look a
little bit strange to put the Rook uh on
a square to where the fork is just uh
begging to be played right again with
only a few seconds I feel like
Jeffrey definitely have very good
chances yes okay uh we'll keep an eye on
that Wesley doing uh sure let's uh I
think that game is almost over
at least it looks that way uh
that's an awfully naked King on the h8
that Wesley has there okay but and the
Knight is still on A8 the Knight never
moved never moved oh my my word he's
just ready
again San sevion is doing outstanding in
the tournament I'm in a great tournament
he came in today's round two out of
three tied with Lavon for second place
and if he puts the kibosh on Wesley so
talk about uh
soaring uh enthusiasm for this event
it's going to just get better and better
for Sam sevillan as he's just played
this move F4 looks very good I want to
go to Lavon and Gary because again these
are our two two tournament co-leaders
things have settled down white did win
upon when we left it Gary purposefully
sacrificed upon in order to get his
Knight on G4 and look at him go Gary
playing with 30 seconds on the clock
okay the players Queen takes D3 Gary's
got a rook on C2 that's great
remember his game with Ray Robson that's
great compensation and he's eyeballing
Knight E3 going after G2 and wait a
minute that's just game over yeah
oh wow can I play Rook F1
King
by the way a draw between Jeffrey Zhang
and Ray Robson
Rook D2 right you cannot go 93 because
of Rook day C3
because he wants to play Rook to E2
trapping The Rook forcing The Exchange
Gary says no no no no no I want to
maintain my offensive rook and I really
desperately want to play 93 Knight F3 E5
93 can I take on this
he finds it yes very good defense
but I mean excuse me very good it may be
good defense but to my mind black is
positionally uh just outstanding oh he's
doing amazing right now and both playing
with 30 seconds so anything can happen
The Rook is a little bit
six Gary bringing the king into the game
by the way guys Hikaru is just about to
win his game against Fabiano that's a
big result with the black pieces oh my
gosh
oh my goodness okay uh
uh Lavon basically begging for the draw
there with Rook E1 rookie two Gary
thinking wait a minute why should I be
making a draw just rejected the draw why
don't I just play Knight E3 I thought he
was going to play King F5 actually I
like the move King G6 like you right
away I thought that night was actually
outstanding game Gary has no risk the
only absolutely the only issue is the
clock because it's so easy to blunder
when you have no time on the clock I
think they're equal on time yes but
still both very long time
Gary is insisting on keeping the Rook
again
King to E4 really had my a moment ago
when The Rook was on D3 King to E4
really had my eye
and even though it's materially equal it
feels like blacks up a pond because of
those doubled pawns and in fact he might
be uh forcing a win of a pawn with the
move E4 oh I like this a foreign
if you don't mind I want to play King E4
that's what he did which invades with
the King and it's such an outstanding
now don't go King D4 I didn't like that
move very much
did win against West Cairo beat Fabi wow
so we're seeing a lot of yes
as we started the abroad please go
forward
G5 or King D4 which one I like G5
because C4
Knight D4 check King G3
and G6 Maybe
just keeping the king out that was a
good move by the way uh how much time is
it 20 seconds for Gary and Ticking he
took on H4 okay okay
and how do you defend both pawns you
don't
how do you do that
I can play King
g42 there's a knight only one I forgot
about that and he's done it but
it's actually calculate this yes he's
got a past e-pawn
sharp right now wow E4 let's go oh it's
Pawn ending so fast oh yeah he knows by
heart but it's in the blood right okay
95 and King D3
yes he can do that as well oh no 95
looks really good
95.3 E3 that looks Unstoppable but wow
and I can't get to G7 Pawn but I don't
have H6 King F6 but
83 instantly wait a minute what's that
what is he doing there why did he play
E3 instantly three night days B2 now oh
this and he took the point 91 and Knight
C3 go for the a pawn Knight D1 and
Knight C3 go 48 makes sense to me
15 seconds 15 seconds before
uh surprise move the move Knight D1
check I can play 90s Knight C3 yeah the
problem is that G7 Pawn if you lose that
guy that H5 Pawn is so close to
promotion wow 91 check these are race
guys this is a big big race right now so
King of the two Knight goes to F2 and
Knight will try to get kingside pawns
while blood king is still going after A2
right okay so there's a Target over here
and there's a Target over here that
white has to keep protected should Lavon
play King C2 and put the King on B I
think so I think it's required actually
Knight C3 he's agreed to keep his Knight
perpetually tied to this Pawn I'm not
sure I'm a fan
of that one night at five no he's played
I was I was thinking there about F5 and
even Knight E4 check it's played Knight
G4 right away again
all right
wow Knight on G4 does not allow Knight
takes F6 any sort of sacrifices I really
like the controlling nature of that
Knight the Knight has dropped back to
see is that an invitation to a draw they
just agree to a draw
which by the way wow objectively that's
yes it's it's looking like a draw wow I
thought that Gary had control but we saw
three more decisive games uh in this
round Fabi versus Hikaru uh by the way
that was a big result and Cara winning
with black that I think is his first
let's just take a look through the magic
of Television we can see the end of
Hikaru Fabi because we were so engrossed
by Lavon let's see what happened in this
one and talk us through it too Christian
tell us they're in a rook ending uh
obviously black has the much more
proficient pieces and the problem is
you're almost forced to go on the first
Rank and that's going to be the downfall
of whitening distribution if you go to
C3 then I can just simply give you
another check exchange the Rooks and
then go for the F Pawn and that's going
to be good if you go in the first rank
which which he did there is going to be
a checkmating pattern coming long like
the two Rooks The Rook could go to F2
and the other one
to come to A1 and in fact you don't have
any uh any way to to stop that route to
H4 King to E5 the king is going to hide
from those chats that's nice and that's
it
as we will see Hikaru goes to E5 right
kind of look pretty confident and has a
lot of time on the clock as well just
simply don't go to G3 because that would
allow the exchange of the Rooks after
Rook to G4 and there was a time travel
for Fabi as well as I can see the clock
ticking underneath 10 seconds but if the
position is Kings getting made it thanks
to Rook A1
or why is losing at least a rock if you
play Rook sister and there's the
handshake wow congratulations to my pick
I don't know how you guys are doing not
not our day so far well that was a clash
between our picks yes sir was it yes and
and who won sorry oh my goodness here we
go again looking for compliments fishing
for compliments what a round three out
of five once again and uh take a look
here's our standings with four in the
books so Gary kasparov's still in the
solid with three points and now we have
four players just half a point behind
Hikaru Nakamura Levon Iranian Wesley so
and Sam Shanklin wait a minute hold on
Wesley lost there's a problem here some
Savion should have two and a half oh yes
right or three uh should have three
points and Western one and a half points
congratulations to our graphic design
artist there where she they were really
close on that one weren't we it was it
we passed the test we were paying
attention Wesley so lost that game to
Sam sevillion that was Wesley's King on
h8 the pawn was on F4 and we thought Sam
sevion was winning but nice uh from Sam
Shanklin for those who are joining us
late shame on you but I just want to
point out this one moment which is just
amazing right here the players had
played eight moves okay and to the
uninitiated eyes nothing's terribly
wrong the pieces look a little funny
night on C7 night on H5 but it was right
here at this moment that Christian
informed us white was plus eight
what
eight moves and you're ahead by eight
well the winning move would have been
Knight F5 a move we a point we pointed
out at the start that G2 and E2 or the
weak squares but after night
at five night takes the idea of King f8
walks into Bishop 25 coming in today and
queen G5 coming as in as well which
would also freeze and hit this Rook that
was a remarkable moment uh Christian oh
yes absolutely and I have to say Sam
sauvian I was looking through the game
as well and uh there was clinical
Precision I think we left it somewhere
around here after Bishop case B3 we were
saying Rook takes C5 is a move and he
played it rotate C5 Queen to D7 Queen to
B3 Pawn up and the initiative you still
haven't developed your pieces and you
still have a soft spot on G7 and keep an
eye on that one because it's going to be
used all throughout the game by white by
Sam Seville Bishop to C3 targeting G7
once again and we got castle of course
don't take on G7 because you get not
made it but you're in big trouble after
Rook to C1 so Bishop takes E5 Queen to
G3 and this was the position I really
like this move H for targeting once
again the G7 and calculating press
precisely because you had to see at this
point don't move the Knight away because
that's going to give me more time I'm
going to be able to go E5 maybe land the
Knight on F4 that's the dream position
for a black but the move H5 very precise
this is not the type of position you
want to see with the black pieces and I
have to say uh it was easy after that
simple as that it was very very easy we
saw it at this point
Samsung oh that's something nice finish
that's a almost a Checkmate yeah take
take boom and queen queen where's the
Checkmate where's the Checkmate there it
is beautiful finish by Sam Smith and
let's take a look at the real standings
are we sure we have a tie for firstness
right after round four there's two
collaters Gary Kasparov and Sam Seville
very nice and the murderers
murderers pack behind them right Hikaru
Nakamura Livonia and Sam shankland just
half a point behind exactly Bobby Wesley
Jeffrey all languishing it minus one at
the moment Lanier and Rey and coming up
in our next round let's take a peek
sneak peek at the pairings we see Lanier
Dominguez playing live on Iranian Wesley
still playing Sunshine Clan Hikaru
against the current leader Sam Savion
nice match Ray against Fabiano and Gary
will be playing Jeffrey exactly looking
to maybe for a full pointer against
Jeffrey Jeffrey not playing great as we
get ready for a break let me just tell
you what's up with our good friends at
the cube Boutique check this out we have
a 9lx t-shirt sport hat and a button up
I kid you not that's what they wrote but
not don't know what that is a 2023 chess
9lx unisex t-shirt is perfect for any
chess player this metallic ink screen
printed shirt is both comfortable and
stylish so you look sharp both on and
off the chessboard we also proud to
present the black button-up shirt that
features the chass 9 LX logo on the
right breast pocket and the official St
Louis chess club logo on this week do we
get a discount for that yeah I hope so
five percent for friends and family last
but not least check out our Black sport
hat that features the chess 9 Alex logo
on the front and the official St Louis
chess Club logo on the bot on the back
plenty of nine LX options so there is
something for everyone do all your
shopping chess shopping needs at Q
Boutique St louis.com and we're going to
be seeing you on the other side of the
blades oh no we gotta reveal we got a
reveal
I think we're waiting for the reveal I
oh they're they're analyzing the game oh
Ray versus Jeffrey
there's nothing like a good post-mortem
and right I can already see the position
I look at Brian Yang the Arbiter in back
yeah waiting maybe has it in the folder
that looks like you know some top secret
confidential you know
the place have a big look at the folder
right yellow folder well the pawn on H6
is so early in the position it looks
like a buck house game you know zero
Alpha zero Pawn
and Ray at the start of the round he was
the loneliest man in the tournament Hall
nobody wanted to be like he had his own
virus or something people did not want
the Ray Robson bug but at last he made a
draw and something changed then it was
okay
and by the way this is the most animated
I've seen Jeffrey Jeffrey's been very
very quiet
and check out Fabi and Wesley taking
over the their game everybody's thinking
Jeffrey's getting in some shots there
he's moving some pieces
so I don't know how to say that was an
exciting game that was a great round H5
H6 and H7 right
I don't know how that happened right by
the way Christian one of the things that
is occurring is very very early in the
sixth move eight move ten moves there
are tactical moments that both sides are
missing like obviously uh Sam Shanklin
Mr chance against Lanier there but
Lanier also he didn't he didn't
recognize the danger of Knight F5 yes
but at the same time Lanier was dropping
on the clock I believe he only had about
eight minutes at that point against 15
for uh Sam he had to play Fast And to be
honest his position was pretty stinky at
that point it really wasn't a good
position is that a scientific chest term
a little stinky white was getting his
shots in and you just had to try to find
a way out and he just needed to play a
few moves fast and hope that he's going
to get lucky he did but unfortunately it
wasn't enough the position was that bad
and there you go we got a reveal he's
giving out the position let's see what
we got nasty Shake the Dice shake the
bottom shake the top
well here he comes
and Bishops again this looks
right the bishop on E1 is the issue with
King on G1 and Rooks right next to it
right now it's on A1 and B1 right
and I think both Bishops are gonna have
at the time right so
one of the things that people who should
you really Fascinate on is the idea that
Knights are actually great Defenders of
the king if in these in this position
you get to play Knight B3 Knight to C3
Bishop for example the E2 Bishop to F2
I'd love to have my king on C1 yeah uh
thank you for asking so uh we're gonna
leave you with that position as well as
the players analyzing and we're going to
take a short break and we're going to
come back for Action in round five see
you right after the break
okay
hello Gary thank you so much for joining
me today when you decided to retire in
2005 many thoughts you wouldn't be back
in the board would you do the same thing
all over again if you had to
absolutely I think the decision to
retire was very Timely because for me
playing chess was not just about winning
but also making a difference
and by 2005 I realized that you know not
that I've exhausted my creative
potential but it didn't bring me the
same pleasure of uh revealing new
secrets of the game of chess and uh I
also wanted to apply my experience my
talents my skills to to things that I
believe were important so that's why it
was a you know to me it was a very
natural shift and the 2005 was an
important year also a marriage so uh
married darsha and you know it's a it's
almost two decades now we have kids we
build a new life so it was just the
beginning of new life
and looking back I think that was one of
the most important and timely and the
wealth of decisions I made though many
thought at the time that it was a very
move uh spontaneous but again I I knew
it was the right moment and now nearly
20 years later I know that that was a
very very good move that I made how do
you deal with with the stress levels
with how much you want to win when you
came back in 2017 was one thing how do
you feel about playing now in this event
oh it's very very different because I'm
an amateur now so I'm no longer playing
chess as a professional I enjoy it
immensely because
um
I could have taken Gary also out of
Chess but I I had no chance of taking
chess out of Gary so it's still part of
my life part of my nature and and this
passion doesn't die so that's why I'm
always
very curious about you know Adventure
the chess board though I I recognize my
shortcomings I'm 60 my concentration is
nearly not the same as it used to be and
many games that I played lately they
were marked by blunders and mistakes
that they were not made 20 years ago but
yeah I enjoy it and I understand you
know many people also happy to see me at
the chess board though you know I'm sure
this is some sort of a Pity because I
you know I I miss many opportunities and
my performance is it's not it's not even
close to what people expected but I
I think it's it's always good to to
um uh challenge your um your skills uh
again recognizing that uh
you're not going to be on top and uh uh
I'm accomplish and lose every year to
say
say to move the pieces because I can
hardly call it playing chess because
playing chess means you would be fully
you know just engaged in every loss when
I play chess professionally was nearly
physical pain now yeah I lose very often
but yet I just I'm happy to continue
playing
this year I I have a very modest goal
just to improve my lousy performance
last year you've played really well I
believe two two years ago you've done
two years ago I did well yes you're
right so that's why again this is this I
don't think I can I can repeat it but
let's say you know just anything in
between you know the two years
performance last year's performance
would be a good good result for someone
who hasn't touched the chess piece
physically I played a lot on the
internet that hasn't touched the chess
piece physically for a year so you
haven't done as much to prepare for this
event or you have played online no I
play online just to have friends so that
again I just did a little bit
preparation but but no matter how much
you you you you you much time you spend
preparing for it it's still about your
concentration and trust me you know this
tournament it's it's for me it's a kind
of entertainment but my head is overload
it now with
much more important priorities so that's
why even if I try to separate myself for
a day or two or three from other things
the ongoing war and all events that
related to this tragic
um uh um this tragedy uh
it's impossible to control your
subconscious so and then and that's what
I discovered around back in 2017 when I
just pretended I could play you know
just uh
um semi-professionally
there were moments where just you know
my concentration elapsed completely so
there were a few games I remember with
nepo and one was with Navara or just you
know I just just before they were blank
spots and
this again no matter what I what I do I
understand it's it's inevitable because
your mind is is working uh on its own
schedule
when when you were training was there
something in particular that you were
doing to improve your is there a
particular exercise that people can use
to improve their visualization skills
look I I never
he never needed you know any special
exercise to improve my concentration or
or or or visual memory so it was I
wouldn't say perfect but it was almost
there and uh
um I'm afraid that the the
idea that you can share some tips it's
might be counterproductive because yes
there's some general advices you can you
you can receive but speaking about
professionals uh trying to to improve
their games you need to actually look at
this person's eyes and also the games
and to understand exactly what is needed
and and very often you know the the
advice that you can give to to a rising
star it's very different depending on
his or her uh playing style
that's that's very true sometimes you
want to give general advice to people
but just general advice is is good but
it is but it's for the beginners you
know that's why you can have a book you
know this up to a certain level general
advice works but if you want to be to be
really good so you have to understand
who you are you understand you look deep
deep inside and to recognize what is
your strengths what are your weaknesses
and how to deal with that and it's it's
Unique it's the decision making
processes as unique as your DNA or
fingerprints so that's why trying to
generalize it it's it's typically it's
counterproductive a final question for
you Gary
you are going to face a lot of the
strongest chess players in America is
there someone in particular you would
you are looking forward to to play
against
I'm here already know just to to to
enjoy myself and uh I think it's it's
probably you know it's worth mentioning
that uh there are several players here
you know who are students of course part
of just such as foundation so and uh and
uh so I already played once was since
I'm trying one but now we have Robson uh
uh Jeffrey uh um and Sam so um first
time I'll play them look again
I'm happy there's a chance for for uh me
to play with them I'm sure they will be
very keen to play and to beat me so
maybe they can do that and so it's uh
you know somehow it's very odd feeling
because when I played professionally so
every game I played I wanted to win and
I believe I was a favorite now I know in
every game I know an underdog this is
something new to learn less pressure
I'm really looking forward to seeing you
play back at the board and wish you good
luck thank you very much thank you
thank you
the Saint Louis chess club will be
hosting its 13th annual charity golf
tournament on October 2nd at Glen Echo
Country Club this charity golf
tournament supports the club's
Scholastic chess initiative in providing
chess to over 100 schools in the St
Louis area to sponsor this event or to
enter your team please go to
stlouischessclub.org and click on the
events tab that's the St Louis chess
club 13th annual charity golf tournament
on October 2nd at Glen Echo Country Club
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 250 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chest
notation in no time we View chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our standings after round four you
got it we have two colliders Gary
Kasparov and Sam sevillan very nice and
closely following three players Hikaru
Nakamura Lavon aranian and Sam Shanklin
right and three players tied with a
minus one score big names too Fabby
Wesley and Jeffrey Zhang at one and a
half Lanier and Ray Robson languishing
at the bottom and I'm not sure if Sam
sevillan is younger than Jeffrey Jacques
but it would be the oldest and the
youngest if it was true who are leading
the tournament in San Sabian indeed is
the year that is true yeah so the oldest
and youngest tied at the top as we see
Sam sevillan on the left and Sam
Shanklin on the right as they're
prepping this uh position and uh
Christian Jump Right In because in this
this opening position I don't know which
position number this is the two Bishops
which one 504 we had 588 I think and now
we have 504s it's the Bishops and the D1
and E1 that are making the poor
impression what what is the uh
development scheme you need to get those
Bishops out of the way and why are you
asking me because you're standing in
front of the database it's funny because
most of most of the positions that we
started off with uh it the engine was
saying maybe plus zero four plus zero
five even in some cases right now is
plus zero one so very very close to an
equal position uh this one is D4 seems
to be uh the best move in the position
or the most played move in the position
E4 is also a way to go and it's the
question of how are you going to connect
uh the knights with the Bishops because
if you go C4 and Knight to B3 the bishop
cannot go out on this angle right if you
go D4 C4 and then the Knight comes to C
E3 then this bishop only one will not be
able to get out so you have to kind of
combine the plan of getting the knights
out with the idea of getting the Bishops
out D4 seems to be the best way D5 very
natural so far Knight to C3 is the most
played move in this position E6 let's
say or Knight to B6 you have to defend
somehow the pawn on D5 and it makes a
lot of sense right this development
scheme from White because you want to
take the center it almost looks like
some sort of a Philly door reversed
Philly door on the other side now if I
go with white E4 Bishop Duty 2 maybe
bishop to F3 this seems to be the scheme
and then you can move the Rook away from
here and then uh jump with the other
Rook on F1 short Castle or once again
the same dilemma you're having you can
go H4 and try to take advantage of uh
potentially more space for white on the
king side then let's take a look at the
pairings right now as we enter this game
five right we have 10 fingers playing
excuse me Iranian Wesley so against Sam
Shanklin he car will play in the current
leader Sam Savion huge matchup right
there Ray Robson against Fabiano caruana
and Gary Kasparov playing another one of
the youngest players Jeffrey Jones
exactly yeah wait a minute am I seeing
this right oh I was about to say they
were analyzing no they're not they're
sitting uh across from one another as
they're getting ready for round five to
begin and uh for Gary Kasparov that was
an important test against levonne
aronian and yet it seemed to me that
Gary was the one pressing in that
contest and most of the game as a d2d4
on the board by Gary I Wonder has
Jeffrey played Gary before
I
think so too wasn't there a uh what do
you call a blitz event I thought there
was some sort of a rapid in the blitz
maybe it could have possibly in some
ways it's quite possible I know last
year Jeffrey was one of the wild cards I
I believe in the rabbit and Blitz I'm
not sure in the St Louis right now
please I mean uh just before the
sinclude cup I'm not sure if Gary was in
that tournament as well and even if he
wasn't I do remember them meeting but
by the way Gary it's played one D4 and
much to my surprise Jeffrey just stopped
he hasn't moved 24 in all five games in
all five games but I was going to pull
up the game of Hikaru for just a moment
because that went actually very fast D4
D5 uh by Sam sevion C4 not that move
Knight C3 that you had were advocating
for uh with E4 to follow but C4
immediately by Hikaru captures captures
Knight developed with Tempo Queen came
all the way back to C1 Knight to A6 a
page right out of a grunfeld where I
think they called it the lodovic prince
variation with Knight to A6 to support
C5
b2b4 no no no you cannot have C5 the
unusual development of the bishop on E1
supports the move uh B4 and we're up to
date with the players we have this exact
same position in the game Wesley against
together
hands out with the exact same openings
exactly by the way uh now that I'm
thinking about it there was this
wonderful confession where a confession
Booth he didn't play b2b4 yet Wesley did
not against Sam Shanklin and I can't
recall who it did Sam Shanklin goes into
the into the confession booth and says
gosh darn it Hikaru he's playing my my
novelty he was standing around me when I
showed this variation in an Olympiad and
he gets to play it and then Hikaru goes
in and he says this is really great I
get to play Sam Champion's novelty
before he does is it
so yeah you're right when they work
together uh sometimes they they they
pickpocket one another and will play
b2b4 uh what is caught your eye
Christian well there are some
similarities between this position the
starting position and the previous one
we have the Queens on this C file right
we have the Rook on the H file and
that's why we see this opening D4 C5 by
Fabiano caruana against Ray Robson D
takes C5 Queen takes C5 we've seen this
actually I said in the last round as
well Knight to B3 Queen to C8 we've seen
it from the white side in hikaru's game
as well with this idea of C4 Queen takes
C4 Queen to C1 so very similar positions
because this is position number 504 we
had position 588 so it seems like
they're very very close in number and
perhaps some of the pieces are on the
same squares quite interesting and I'm
looking forward to see how these players
are going to deal with that and how
they're going try to connect the dots
once again between the patterns by the
way uh d2d4 by Gary kaspara D7 D6 by uh
Jeffrey Zhang as he doesn't go for uh
the the Symmetry that we've been seeing
in a number of the games which led up to
C4 Gary has actually taken some time now
because I mean normally speaking when
you get to play D4 and your opponent's
playing like a perk you really want to
follow it up with the move E2 E4 and
Gary is probably just considering you
know like okay the bishop it's an
unusual move right the bishop popping
out to B5 of course that would induce
c2c4 but E4 let's say I play E5 and it's
kind of like a a philodor with the
Knights jumping
um unusual uh yeah where's my knight on
G1 to go to F3 right I have three to
attack the pawn on E5
and Gary is actually used uh three
minutes yeah but Jeffrey also spent
about two minutes on his first move so
they're they're slow playing it uh I
don't think we looked at the game
between Lanier and Lavon always whenever
I I look at games of Lavon you know I
just don't know if I'm on the same
Planet as Lavon half the time D4 guess
what uh a page from Jeffrey's which
players Analyze This Together exactly E2
E4 okay Lanier says I'll take the center
if you don't mind
on the board technically it looks that
way and Lanier says okay let's play
Sicilian but no suitcase D4 B5
right B5 okay
uh
this too way way uh a very unusual
patches yes very unusual patterns for me
um there are no moves that come to mind
because it's so unusual
yeah it's funny I you can check this out
this was my first move
not obvious but I was thinking that I
want to put pressure on the c5e the
force you to capture or force you to
play the move C4 and the only way I
could put pressure on C5 that made sense
to me was F4 and Bishop F2 can capture
and go Bishop B6 but you're ready to
meet that with
two yes I am that's good that maybe
Knight C6
looks good and here we do feel I do feel
like we're well okay it's not completely
familiar ground but it does feel a
little oh we did have a take on C5 uh
Sicilian Ash physician D take C5 and C4
and C2 C4
okay
that makes sense now if you go B4 I will
go with your idea of f4 Bishop no that
would be that would be a kind of a dream
come true because we've we've really
fixed and targeted a weakness I think uh
C4
the question I would ask is what about
takes yes yes if you take which is kind
of natural I want to try to induce you
that there's a bishop B5 at the end of
the day right if you take on C5 uh that
I have waiting in ambush
um what do you think is Lanier intending
Knight D2 maybe you can still play
Knight B6 and on Knight C4 Bishop B5 and
then Knight A3 right
um okay that's a very unusual move right
like it defend it hits the bishop and it
defends the Knight it's kind of funny
right perhaps he just wants to take on
C4 Knight B6 and then just go back with
the queen queen C2 maybe like we kind of
saw
Knight B6 trying to coax
takes so he could recapture the better
move order because now I can't play
Knight A3
guess what then take a look at this uh
beautiful pattern in fact we haven't
spotted it and I'm sure the players will
not either take on B5 okay take on B5
yep
Bishop C3
whoa you see it now whoa that's the
Apple that day which is a kind of a
funny one right you don't yeah with the
epaulettes you think of a a general with
uh the metals on the shoulders right
that's beautiful yeah that truly is
beautiful I mean it's an easy one to
miss of course it's so easy to miss
which kind of begs the question why do I
have to take on B5 can I play the move
Bishop C3 and set that up
yes Bishop C3 was a move by the way we
do have Knight D2 on the board which
buried the bishop when you play a move
like night I don't think Bishop C3 can
easily come to mind exactly well when
you play Move light Knight D2 the bishop
on C3 you can almost hear it say wait a
minute wait a minute why did you do that
to me why did you uh block my
perspective if the position E5 I'm not a
fan of this Knight D2
maybe it's not as bad as it would appear
after Bishop E2 but uh
yeah the bishop is one of the thing is
if you don't see that Bishop C3 right
you kind of go for this Knight D2 right
that Bishop C3 is just a beautiful
pattern easily uh missed easily missed
easily missed okay well keep an eye on
that let's jump to the game of Hikaru uh
and Sam Savion why because I always want
to give the respect that the leaders of
the event deserve and so like in every
hikaru's game there's H4 H5 no matter
what the starting position pause on H4
and H5 okay and it's Hikaru who has he
but Hikaru didn't wasn't the one who
induced uh the age it was Sam who played
H5 himself and then Knight Bishop A4
that's a surprising move that decision
to just voluntarily give up the light
squared Bishop I don't think that comes
very natural well the problem is
back into the game the only way or at
least one of the ways to do that is to
go C6 right C6 Knight C7 but C6 burries
the bishop only eight so perhaps this
was his uh train of thought that makes
sense and by the way the current
position I mean yeah had soft to Sam
Savion is uh he's uh he's going for a
pawn uh but I sent both of them with
Queen F4 yeah yeah now this looks good
for white I have to say
uh let's just play a move or two just to
see okay I liked your idea of C6 Knight
C7 and I I mean it's just an advantage
of the two Bishops is that what you
think yes Rook H3 Rook H3 oh sorry yeah
Queen F4 C6 Rook H3 because he wants to
meet us
she does don't be fooled don't be fooled
no okay go ahead show us the checkpoint
Knight C7 are you gonna are you really
gonna meet us Rook over
uh
really
oh my okay you know I can't I I can
resistance anything but Temptation I was
going to take your Pawn you don't want
to take an exchange
well when I can take apart no uh but but
it's not made on G7
no no there's no epilepsy anymore not
anymore no no no no no uh okay well
we'll see what uh bishop and E1 to
participate and truly not easy not easy
uh I'm just going to check in on Ray
Robson versus Bobby Because by the way
remember when I was saying F4 and Bishop
F2 yeah well we we got an echo in this
one by the way D4 it became popular as
D6 and it does look like we have open
Sicilians this move Rook E1 or what uh
Christian mentioned a Prelude to Simply
castling the Rooks will suddenly end up
on E1 and F1 that'd be fantastic it
reminds me of a sicilian right now I
mean definitely The Rook on F1 you get
Bishop on F3 and it's some sort of a
Chevy engine or something like that
right I mean you put the bishop over
here you put the Knight over here you
put the bishop only if the Rook would be
on C8 you know or on the other one
should be on D3 I guess yes that that
will easily find that maneuver again
we're seeing this move H7 H5 uh by black
uh by Fabi uh let's just check but
someone somehow given that white is
closer to looking like a real game
position feels like it gives him the
advantage right well with H5 in this
position yes yeah with Bobby's position
fabi's position just seems to be more
natural at least the way we think about
uh chess compared to classical chess but
guys let's take a look at what happened
in this game between Wesley and Sam
because this connects very well with uh
Hikaru versus Sevilla let's now forget
Sevilla and Sam are analyzing together
so take a look at this after B4 I
believe Savion play the move E6 followed
by Bishop to E7 and unfortunately he has
some problems with the Knight on H6
still to solve but take a look at this
E5 this is a Sam Shanklin uh
I really like it
D takes C5 Bishop to E7 what's the idea
well the idea is to release the tension
on the queen side after the move C5
there's no more Pawn on D4 you don't
stop me from going C5 and I have to say
from a visual perspective it looks quite
decent for black I like what I'm seeing
A3 C5 Bishop to B4 Bishop to B5 all all
of his pieces are coming out nicely and
uh this is what we have right now the
onus is on why to preserve his extra
Pawn on E5 and finish the development at
the same time or shortly so this is not
going to be easy I have to say despite
of the objective eval that says that
perhaps white is uh quite
um a lot better or close to 0.1 right
now it does seem like black has enough
compensation at least in my estimation
well talking about
preservation of the pawn Wesley so heard
you Christian and he played the move F2
F4 it did yeah so as Christian was
saying why it's close to plus one the
engine
commentators I recognize the same same
thing the engine went down F4 was not a
good move by the way what would be the
move that you guys would play in this
position well I'm just looking at this
King on G1 and I'm just a little bit
Ultra sensitive to any checks on that
diagonal Castle yes let's just get the
king out of there right
that's a move that that exists
oh no Rook f8 but long castles why would
that have been because now my Ford is
not scary anymore and oh you're not you
you know you're just getting your king
away from any repercussions of that
foreign
what was played was the move Rook f8
which foreign
let's say I'm just going to put a move
on the board more natural for me is that
black would want to Castle short but I
can understand why you want to cast
along and avoid any potential you know
ideas of uh Queen E3 and queen G3
dangerous black doesn't have any pieces
around the king no no Palace easy to
move your Knights over so okay so that
was the game with E5 and now we're going
to go back to hikaru's game for a moment
because Again Sam savionish and sharing
the lead with Gary Kasparov at this
moment
okay a solid setup for both players
White having the two Bishops yeah that's
going to be a grind that's going to be a
grind but let's cut your eyes Gary and
well what caught my eye is that Gary and
Jeffrey only played Four moves
and nobody has any time
well mostly Gary Gary doesn't have a lot
of time left he just played this move a
C4 this is move five and he only says C4
and he only has nine minutes left on his
clock oh my goodness C4 Wild Horses
wouldn't have
allowed me to play C4 C4 why do you
dislike this move so much because of the
D4 Square just you know you're giving uh
the potential Outpost to your opponent
your opponent has not played C5 if I
played C5 here what what goes to your
mind immediately it's a three Knight C3
95 right like that that is as As Natural
as a baby smile when you play the move
C4 here
Knight C6 I mean again you know as
natural as a baby smile you want to
Black and play C6 instead of C5
precisely that's why I was saying that I
find the move C4 so
counterintuitive I mean Gary must have
been fighting with himself when you see
the idea you also say to yourself well
is it a good one will it work he must
have been fighting you know all of his
knowledge base to play such a move to C4
but the problem with Knight C6
yes yes yes exactly what I'm worried
about if you do go Knight D4 I'll
exchange that and then stop you with C5
that that was I mean doubtlessly it was
something of this nature that he was
calculating when playing that move C4 I
mean I'm just worried about the Knight
on A8 she did spend more than five
minutes before he played C4 so it's not
an easy move it's not uh one that you I
mean it
you have to share some responsibility
you know when you make a move like uh C4
that's 25 of your time to spend on one
move exactly so that is so it is kind of
funny if we do play C5 and you do play
Knight C3 we do play Knight C6 and you
do for argument's sake play Knight D4
and we do play Knight B6 it might be one
of those strange situations where we we
keep copying one another you you know
like did you ever do that uh when you
were starting in chess for sure you went
through these permutations what if I do
the same thing what if I do the same
thing usually that goes well for white
yes
I discovered that too I said
look at the face I'm gonna Gary you Gary
looks like he's bit into a sour lemon
there I mean I think it just doesn't
like the position the setup no and again
the move C4
um how did the engine light to move C4
uh Christian they liked it just fine
yeah it was just fine was it a top pick
uh the second what was the first Knight
C3 Knight B3 excuse me B3 yes it's C5
again it's it's very close uh they're
very close to each other and I would
assume if I play Knight C3 on the board
the engine eval is not going to change
much so I think you have a lot of ways
of developing your PCS right now c4 is
not a bad way by any means
Knight to C6 by the way I'm not
convinced about this Knight B3 let's see
about this variation that we are looking
at and indeed after C5
the engine is starting to give white
quite a significant Edge 0.7 if you play
the best moves uh almost in one point
Advantage if you start uhurring in the
position so not looking good for black
in this one night C6 is indeed at least
to my eyes a very natural move but it's
not going to be easy uh to play because
Jeffrey is calculating all of these
things
okay uh by the way he's catching up on
time almost yeah well if I'm in
Jeffrey's shoes one of the moves that I
you know it captures he's played Knight
C6 and we're going to see Knight C2
right away not Knight B3 but Knight C2
maybe the more natural way just because
you have ideas of Knight E3 Knight D5 as
well
or Knight F5 yeah I just wanted to say
that just at the moment that Jeffrey was
reaching for his Knight to play Knight
C6 one of the moves that I would have
found myself drawn to is the move C6 why
because I just take away the D5 square
and let's just say for argument's sake
that you play Knight C3 and Knight C2 so
again my idea is you know like I do want
to control the D4 Square
um
G4 oh Bishop G4 Bishop
57 yeah but you know what I'm saying
something of the nature where the fight
over the D5 and D4 squares is prominent
that not that did not happen I'm going
to refresh what did happen was Knight C6
Knight C2 and Christian uh guide us to
where we should go next the action is in
fobby's game Bobby with the black pieces
against Rey in trouble right now take a
look at this position we were discussing
it it looked very similar to a sicilian
yes but naturally the pieces were
looking much better for white look at
the Bishops the queen is not very well
placed the Knight on B6 not tremendous
uh in that position this is what we have
right now and it just feels easy to play
with white I'm going to go Knight F5 and
this is exactly what he wants he just
played the move Knight D4 the natural
follow-up would be to go Knight to F5
put pressure on the D6 pawn queen to E6
and then stop the knight from entering
The Fray via C4 either this one on B6 or
the one on E5 I'm looking at the
position I don't see big plans for black
I see an easy position for white I'm
going to get this Knight out of the way
maybe even go C4 transfer this Knight to
D4 it just looks easy to play for white
black doesn't have a plan I'm not liking
it for Fabi in this one take a look uh
how are we doing on time 8 minutes and
30 seconds for rate 10 minutes for Fabi
so still some pressure on the clock for
Fabi but I'm not sure if that's going to
be enough Ray
um must be feeling good about the
outcome of the opening quote-unquote I
mean not having less than five minutes
after that already it's a major success
yes so I think he's doing great right
now I mean you know sometimes you need
to play yourself in the form that day
one experience that Ray had of spending
too much time uh kind of electrified him
and yeah it does feel like Rey is
enjoying the proceedings as jump to the
game of Wesley so and uh Sam Shanklin uh
when we left it it was just the move F2
F4 it moved the computer did not like a
lot of White's Advantage Way Long Castle
it didn't happen Rook C8 did happen Rook
F3 this is a kind of a funny way of
doubling Brooks right
and that is very cool I know right and
there you have it double drugs but for
the moment it sure feels good for Wesley
he's enjoying uh The Spoils of an extra
Pawn but more importantly F5 F6 is just
Splat that would be a Checkmate uh you
think black needs to play F6 very
quickly to avoid some of it yeah because
I mean I'm seeing F5 F6 and I don't have
to see anything further I just know that
you know with this queen ready to jump
to age six again you put the pawn on F6
you put the queen on H6 that's automatic
so
defensively speaking well F6 or F5 I
think is actually mandatory to stay in
the game uh Christian is that uh right I
mean is Sam in trouble here the pawn
sacrifice didn't pan out yes his uh in
some danger and he has to be very
careful I think the best way to defend
against this F5 F6 is to actually play
F6 yourself yeah but that's not an easy
move to make no it truly isn't because
you're a pawn down but sure you have
some compensation there is double pawns
on the e-file but that pawn on E5 that
double Pawn is a strong Pawn right now
it's supporting a lot of White's attack
so that's why he has to understand and
that's why he has to play the move F6
again not easy uh but it might be forced
you might be seeing ideas of F5s
he did not find it he's playing with
fire is the same Shanker and now F5 is a
really strong move I think his idea is
to meet F5 with Knight D4 for sure
you have to yeah that looks like uh but
now I take on D4
take back and F6 let's go F6 yeah
Queen C5
Queen C5 or queen E5 which one oh Queen
yes that's the point and queen C5 I just
moved my key I go King H1
F3 is doing such a good job
C3 uh which kind of begged me the
question when you played the move Knight
D4 uh I was wondering about
the immediate F6 is I guess
I I shouldn't I shouldn't be playing
these types of games that's the thing
that's the thing you shouldn't right I
mean your position is already very good
it's so good don't worry about giving
material just keep the material balanced
as is and just go for the checkmate
feels right by the way again just
because the attack is just so righteous
Rook H3
give me the pawn if you play G6 which
you may
regret right
I mean this is it this is an attack
that's the problem sometimes it's nice
when the path is very narrow and you
don't have such uh excellent options but
Rook H3 also looks pretty good uh I want
to go back to Sam Sauvignon and he
played F5 Wesley how could you resist
right yeah I mean
I think Wesley is finally going to get a
victory in this one which by the way
no this is not his first Victory he
bounced back after he lost against Gary
in the first round so yeah he got a
victory in the second round but after
that he's been struggling let me just
look at the game Dominguez Iranian
because there's a lot of traffic on the
defile
we were talking about the Knights of of
Gary and Jeffrey Zhang a night on D5
tonight on D4 well we're seeing an echo
of Lanier and Lavon here and somehow the
move C5 and C4 have been played on both
boards
that is funny Knight a192 I was about to
say boy it took a while to get there
they got that is strange uh let me go to
Hikaru and Sam Savion because once again
these two players are leading the
tournament if we discount the fact that
uh Gary is tied for first with Sam uh
Hikaru decided that he was ready to give
up his Queen side in order to achieve a
majority on the king side and check this
out it's last note G4 wow okay that's a
visual
that is an interesting movie what if I
take that part can we take on H4
on H4 I thought you were taking on B4 it
didn't occur to me that you wanted to
you want to open up the Rook on H5
dangerous right I mean you
you have nerves of Steel look at this
it's not Mikey good point uh Rook uh boy
I like this move G4
you like the move G4 the engines hated
but I like it uh I suppose now see I
could play E4
my C7 let's say Okay so this guy's
hanging I don't and I want to magically
excuse me I want to magically bring my
queen to H3 I'm not oh not not that way
apologies kingside is actually weaker I
don't know I'm I'm trying to figure it
out myself I wanted to oh Queen G5 yeah
this is a weird I I'm sorry I don't I
don't have the Zen of the position here
I'm not sure what I'm supposed to do uh
Bishop takes H4 yeah I could play such a
okay let's go E5 let's go E4 and you
know just intending to use the H file
one day strange position uh Christian
jump in what do you what what do you
reckon let's go E4 after Bishop H4 I
think it's critical right because if you
okay allow me to go G5
you might have some problems or Knight
F4 followed by uh G5
okay if you don't think on H4 I like my
position so how okay I think we're going
Knight C7 and now let's go maybe bishop
to D2 I really don't like this queen to
G5 idea so you don't worry about this
because this guy is hanging yes okay but
you can go Knight C3 Knight C2 does look
good uh
and let's not forget
black will be able to castle at some
point right get the queen out of the way
and go Castle castles go inside that
would be hilarious on the other side
you're trying you're attacking with all
your vim and vigor along the H file and
suddenly your opponent goes King B8 he's
like what but that's I mean if I manage
to Castle on that side of this game that
that would be your attack is over uh
sorry I'm just going to refresh the
board for a moment because G4 is on the
board and uh Sam sevion I thought you
guys wanted to you know capture the
queen side and you know just deal with
ramifications of G5 it won't happen but
Bishop takes H4 is remarkable Bishop B4
doesn't work because of Bishop D5 I
think
sorry Bishop takes B4 does not work
because if Bishop takes D5 and in
between moves you've got it before
Bishop E4 yeah uh fair enough yeah I
won't argue that that uh that's well
maybe
suddenly it just occurred to me that the
king is still on um
the G file so at the move F5
is available crazy position
um what the way he did not take that
pawn he played The Rook H6
did Sam what is Sam trying to do after
G5 is he trying to go back to h8
so he's inducing okay well let's go G5 I
think he wants to go back to h8
that's a funny maneuver and he does want
to Castle long now right yes yeah he
went to it
who needs to move the queen
and castle
like that the G7 Pawn hangs but then
you're the one attacking my king
so he lost the pawns G4 right and then
went back with the Rook to AJ
wow this is so weird and this is how you
get
yourself in first place
is you trick your opponents wow uh let's
jump to our other co-leaders game and
that's Gary Kasparov versus Jeffrey
Zhang and special finally looks very
normal except for the Rooks on H1 and h8
right okay just a second so we get this
okay looks like you say very normal
position except for the Rooks right and
both but you know what I can quickly
Castle uh
I know you've got a protective pass Pawn
on D4 but it's so firmly blockaded and
the mobility of E5 and F5 and we do have
a castles I suspect we'll see something
uh let me just put a moves some moves on
the board so I can just get this so if
it's white you know we're seeing
um
this E5 F5 business
across uh the round the Knight on C7 is
too passive it looks it looks good for
and
we see it now um are we so Rook up too
yes very yes double the Rooks uh like
Wesley did Wesley went Rook F3 Jerry's
doubling his Rooks and again Gary is
looking for the attack this looks
promising uh Christian oh yes for uh
Gary absolutely and they're very close
in time as well Gary is keeping Pace
with the youngsters the youngsters so
he's definitely looking good in this one
and I have to say these are not
Jeffrey's type of positions he doesn't
like to defend that much and uh this is
a defensive position you don't have
space F5 is coming the other on the F1
will be transferred like that it's
looking good for Gary three minutes for
Gary chrispara for almost five minutes
for Jeff things are really hitting up in
Wesley Franklin game there's some
sacrifices
wow my goodness itch but boy I think
it's it's it's Wesley having the fun
though right F6 what a blast
damn bam
give me that guy and this guy is hanging
so Knight H7 you have a rook G6 check
first that's an important Intermezzo
your King has to go into the corner and
I'm grabbing The Rook which five only
move
and then
where's two pieces for the rug maybe
life is actually fine if there's no
checkmate
no it must be checked me just a second
I'm thinking Knight C5 in order to play
rookie six and takes thinking Rook F5
no just hold on wait a minute this black
minor pieces can come into the game
really quickly Knight C4 or or Knight D5
this is weird I would have thought that
it's game over but some took with the
queen on H7 okay just second uh Let me
refresh them at the board it's probably
safer for his King
uh and he took back uh bent Larson
famously chimed a night on f8 and I
don't get made it uh we'll see if that's
true Queen takes H7 Queen takes C3 it's
that material disadvantage that you
spoke of or two minor yeah in the
material imbalance to minors versus The
Rook are we wait is there an id5 yeah
that that was my question
95 Queen G3 check Queen G7
black should
okay even if Queen's come off but much
better blacks Black's happy I do have
Knight D5 on the board
do I have anything else besides coin two
three
I'm hearing that actually white has
Queen D2 instead of Queen G3 uh makes
much more sense Knight D5 Queen D2 and
apparently White's doing great pinning
pinning the Knight and it's okay Knight
F6 28 yes can I defend both nights and
we do have Queen D2 by Wesley on the
board I mean these positions are so
difficult
oh that's nasty sorry Christian you were
saying it's so difficult to defend these
positions
he just thought that Queen G3 is
probably forced well Queen G3 Queen G7
and we were in total agreement that
blackhead weathered the storm yes
exactly and
he wanted that he wanted that check he
wanted that trade of the queen so that
the king can feel a bit safer yeah no
this McQueen D2 is definitely
uh thrown uh monkey wrench into Sam's
Club right now
my question is which Rook on F3 can I
gonna play with the six just because
it's hanging help me out here what am I
missing folks if I play Rook house if I
could just take that twice then I go E4
and I say may I introduce you to the
back pin so what we're talking about is
takes takes takes E4 and I win material
so there is Rook F7 but I also like what
you said
is it may is it is it the moment to say
how how strong these are they don't miss
anything
Rook at seven Rook S7 uh and it's two
minutes to two and queen E5
Queen E5 wanting to play Queen E3
oh
not nice
um I feel we have to go back to the
leaders right now you can pick whichever
one you want because both positions are
let me go to Gary and Jeffrey just
because when we left it we really
thought that oh Gary didn't Castle how
could he not Castle he after the move G6
I really expected Castle short he played
the move F5 bishop and Jeffrey said just
a second if you overlook something
Knight F1 no I haven't I'm intending H4
A3 Queen
um what's happening put a knight on F1
well the nice honest one he wants to uh
play the move H4 he wants to go H4 H5
okay we open up the position like that
but is Bishop E3 uh that's the problem
the monkey wrench that's the problem yes
and in fact H4 would have been a good
move but the problem is after Bishop P3
you have to take take another very
natural move Rook to E2 because of Queen
to D4 and your opponent E4 uh hangs and
you're going to lose that
but in fact Rook to F4 was the only move
he has played not H4 he has played
Queenie too yes a Prelude to the move H4
I like it and what is it like times
one minute 40 seconds for Jeffrey one
minute 15 16 for Gary so very close time
if you don't mind to make it an
executive decision and say let's keep an
a close watchful eye on this one for the
rest of the round sorry to the apologies
to everybody else but uh this is uh this
is
chat this is Fisher 9lx but this is
chess as well as former world champion
Gary Kasparov we got to stay with us
getting his attack and he's getting his
Mojo going he had a better move instead
of Queen G4 E5 he's really strong if I
was a big one yeah okay because Queen G4
looks so attractive you want to play H4
you want to play in 25. I understand but
you know I'm I I'm inducing some kind of
weaknesses let's go for it let's go we
have to go for it right problem with
this attack is that my knight is so
passive pieces
yeah I kind of feel you there I I yes I
I I'm in agreement but
for the moment this night on A6 is
really off 25 seconds for Gary Gary
clock is ticking and now he is going to
be time to make a move he's shaking his
head he doesn't like the position I
think he I think he's regretting Queen
G4 okay too
he missed something I did some night ba
tonight
I was about to say the knights you know
and instantly Jeffrey is in agreement
castles
97 97 Knight F3
I'm still not happy
but he he does have ideas right
there's a pawn hanging here what black
and play
Bishop E4 and H5 or H5 and then Bishop
B4
Bishop e not easy to see not easy for H5
Queen here G5 yes yes
whoa and we see H5 H5 Queen H3 so now
apologies let me just refresh my board
uh
sacrificed upon I'm not sacrificed it
yeah I'm not sure what it is
Bishop D6 he's reaching for his Bishop
is Gary but I cannot say that he could
take on G6 as well
do you think I think eight six six you
got to make five oh he's going he's
going to lose my time he's lost on time
oh yeah Gary didn't trust his instincts
and by the way
after Bishop to D6 uh it's minus three
so minus three so that's your queen G4
he was really unhappy with the position
right let's jump to the Hikaru Nakamura
Sam sabrian and Wesley so also won his
game against Sam Shanklin that was the
two Rooks on the open file and Sam
sevillion has a chance the door is wide
open
uh can he
come on
okay he might win a second one hold on
we've got Rook takes D5 right we've got
the Intermezzo no Queen C7 apologies uh
E7 is having it yeah everything but
there is Queen G4 cage for maids so
and he's decided to take and quickly
Rook takes C Rook takes H4 no internet
I'm not happy he's not looking happy
that is for sure it takes
either in D5 or G6 Knight takes
G6 by the way
what a journey that Rook had Rook H6
and he's done it nine seconds did you
say
that's cutting it close Knight takes G6
on the board as indicated so we can take
on G6 takes on E7 we've got a rook G4
check he's done it he's taken up you
have to take on E7 right now don't go
Queen e67. five seconds
wow that was a kind of a queen's on the
on the board because if you've come off
well B4 is hanging true so Queen E7
rookie seven Rook B4 is something you
don't just immediately discount do I
have Queen B8 right now
Queen
of the eight or you will simply play
Queen E5
well I I can indeed Force the queen
trade but anyway taking the queen Rook
G4 oh he's taken up before as expected
right not sure but now can I take on D5
and double up on the seven well I was
expecting Rook F7 it's probably the only
move
first all right now we can move the king
they both have 10 seconds oh it feels
like uh a draw is in the offing suddenly
well
still these four Rook Endings by the yes
weird things can happen we can go check
check we can we can check on F1 check on
F2 and play Rook at five seconds for
some yes he's not forget about the time
it's so easy isn't it
yeah
two seconds
he made it on one second
I think
I think Rook D7 might be he takes okay
yeah and now there's no way to get out
of this paralysis yeah okay this one uh
we've got Lanier domain it's a fabulous
game sure Ray Robson
we will keep an eye on this one but
we're going to go to Ray Robson and Fabi
as the clocks are 16 seconds
okay I don't understand anything from it
I can't understand like there's way too
many pieces so many pieces on the board
uh how have they not exchanged as a
professional commentator you cannot
allow yourself to say I don't understand
anything what's going on give me seconds
three oh we made that move with two
seconds
don't lose that B3 pawn queen
crafting that was a frustrating to play
with no time
Terrible's position I mean look at his
brain he's like a hawk looking at the
board right now look at that seven
seconds D5 good move D5
tags we're anticipating Queen takes Rook
D1 uh no Queen take Rook takes one right
yes oh he took with the rock six seconds
three seconds
anything's possible in this position but
uh Bishop F Rook D2 Bishop F4 two
seconds
oh my goodness
he is nervous right now to watch truly
but C6 is hanging there's a knight on C6
hanging alert and there's eight seconds
on the clock and I think Ray has been
playing with this five seconds for the
last 20 moves H4 is hanging Mike oh no
my pawn my Spidey is four seconds he
took it
the pawn but he's allowed Rook D1 and
maybe it's black Rook D1 Queen takes F6
oh don't miss that I missed it I
certainly missed it oh Bishop F4 G5 it's
okay Queen G3 or queen G no Queen G4 is
on possible one oh what he flagged oh my
goodness Ray flagged I was used to
seeing Ray make you know five moves with
one second in the increment he mistimed
it what a nervous wow and by the way
four four seconds
only Hikaru and Sam said beyond the
tournament leaders were able to make a
draw decisive games all around Christian
uh what was going on at the end of that
game in terms of the engines assessments
Bishop to F4 was indeed uh the blunder
yes the final blunder because after G5
there's very difficult task ahead of
yourself Queen to G4 once again doesn't
work Queen takes G4 and then the bishop
Falls Queen to G3 seems to be the only
move but then this is what he saw this
is wow stopped worried about Rook to D3
and the only way to get out of this is
Bishop to E3 the problem is after Bishop
to C5 you have to deal with so many pins
in the position it is black who is in
front and after for example Rook to E1
is just simple to play Knight to E5
Knight takes C4 is coming centralize
everything this position is just looking
really juicy for a black black is in
pole position in fact black is
completely winning right now
um so Bishop to F4 that was the final
mistake even if you do give up the piece
sure maybe you get some chances and with
low time control he definitely had still
some practical shots ahead of himself
but he flagged that's it our tournament
co-leader Gary Kasparov has regaled is
through four rounds because see him at
the very end of this tough loss that he
just had against Jeffrey and Jeffrey
said excuse me uh
and Gary just like ah total disgust I
forgot about my clock no Hardy
handshakes so congratulations well well
done young man uh none of that stuff but
let's take a look at the standings after
five
rounds of play things have changed we
have a new leader Lebon aronian joining
Sam Savion
Gary Kasparov dropping to third Sharon
third with Hikaru Nakamura and then with
two and a half points Fabiano Wesley and
Son Shanklin very very nice Ray Jeff
Lanier just still struggling in the
Fisher random I'm still kind of like
disappointed because you know it was if
you don't mind bring up that game of
Gary and Jeffrey for a moment because I
thought that Gary had worked up a pretty
nice looking attack before the move
Queen G4 tell us about the position
after Queen to G4 he started started
shaking his head like he knew something
was wrong after Bishop to F6 because
after Bishop to F6 you have full control
over the E5 square and nicely played
Knight to ba Knight to D7 red rocking
the Knight to E5 very nicely played by
Jeffrey I have to say but as Nazi
pointed out E5 immediately was completed
winning winning that was my I was gonna
ask isn't white better devastating
attack right now because not only Queen
to G4 is coming and then you were having
some problems with the bishop but it's
all about this E6 move and then your
king wants you for example E6 you take I
take on G6 this is over right wow
everything opens up your king is no
longer safe and you're going to get
checkmated this one was the critical
shot that Gary surely has seen but
probably that decision making in those
last few seconds that's the difficult
part of Chess and just I know that's
Queen G4 what a culprit that was and he
knew it he knew it that's the thing you
know he played it Bishop F6 and he knew
it he understood that he no longer has
an advantage he still feels the
positions
and something I am just not used to
seeing whatsoever is Ray Robson losing
on time Ray Robson in time trouble sure
happens all the time but raise clock
falling no he's got seven seconds and
Rey's just like staring and he usually
makes his move with a second despair
he never loses on time never he
participated here and that's found and
there it is so wait too late like just a
fraction of a second there you see it uh
it's just
and let's take a peek ahead let's take a
look at our pairings for our sixth and
final round of today Nasi please right
the new leader Levon Iranian will be
playing Jefferson who's feeling a little
bit better about his tournament result
thanks to his victory in this last round
and Fabi after his win is going to play
Gary kasparo uh some anger going to go
on in that game yes indeed another
co-leader Sam Sabian will be playing Ray
Robson who's not having the best
tournament they will love to play
spoiler for sure some shankland against
the Carolina
Dominguez against Wesley Ah that's a
very nice matchup but look at the scores
yes Ray and Lanier are the only ones
that are falling behind everybody else
they're so close to each other right two
and a half points and up so this one is
a very very close tournament still
anybody's tournament right now yeah as
you say not much separates the top eight
players as a players in ninth and ten
that are really languishing there yes
the players is kind of getting a little
break you know get rid of the tensions
uh what is what has gone wrong uh for
Lanier in this uh I I didn't follow too
closely his uh round of five game with
Lavon but I I thought it was balanced uh
Christian where was it was this also a
big blunder remember both players had
these Knights on D5 and D4 what happened
I don't think it was a blunder I think
at this point he just missed a beat in
this position what he was supposed to do
according to the engines at least it was
to reroute the Knight as fast as
possible to D5 Knight F1 Knight E3
Knight D5 he missed a bit with the move
Knight to A1 he wanted to exchange the
light Square Bishops first but after
Bishop to D7 Knight to C2 it was black
who got the Knight first sure Knight to
D5 comes but let's take a look Rook 28
take on deep for this doesn't seem to be
the right way and let's keep going let's
keep going nothing is happening dramatic
up to this point but you do have to
worry about this attack Brewing on the
king side and especially after the move
F4 I have ideas of not only Bishop to E7
and Target The Pawn on H4 but also maybe
at some point Rook to G3 right right
sacrifices along the G fight like that
let's see what happened King to H7 Rook
12 f8 still shuffling the pieces the
computer is saying zero zero and you
don't have a way to break much is
happening with either side right and
let's see how he did break in the
position he decided to create another
Avenue for his attack
goes to A3 most likely nope
and now there's not a good way to defend
the pawn on H4 still a lot of shop wait
zero zeros
they don't just lose on time do we have
that on camera by any chance
he might have lost some time another
player I'm not used to seeing lose on
time there's also like Ray Robson he did
lose on time guys oh and the final
position is dead even like if you play
Rook C6 in that position like
maybe we can through the magic of
Television I don't know but we we our
cameras may have been fixated on uh Gary
and Jeffrey there at the end okay so uh
fortunate uh for Lavon which explains
how he's in first place
we need some luck to win the tournament
no question about it as we get ready for
our reveal for our sixth and final
rounds just re to remind everybody we
are playing three games of Rapid chess
per day we are in day two tomorrow is
our third and final uh
day of three games of Rapid but as Nasi
has said in case we do have a tie we
will be playing tie breaks as one very
unhappy Gary Kasparov seems to be you
know storming around the playing Hall
yeah pacing
it's definitely
when the break is only 15 min
by the way that was a remarkable game
that Sam Savion played with Hikaru
Nakamura played Rook H6
all the way back to h8 and somehow ended
up upon a head in The Rook ending how do
you do that that was a remarkable magic
of chest nine eleven right as all the
players seem to be uh looking at this
post-mortem for Gary
yeah Gary's is pacing and
periodically uh glancing and they are
looking at Rey's game right versus with
uh Fabi that moved Queen F7
yeah there was so much going on there's
still a lot of pieces on the board and
both players had under 10 seconds
exactly so hard to play
Knight to D4
yeah oh Hikaru joined Gary
slight discussion
as to ameliorate his pain right
Gary is explaining what what how could I
miss E5 you know if I played E5 that
would have been just a winning position
reminds me of uh your story about the
winter night when YouTube had
yes a difficult time exactly there it
was uh Hikaru taking some of the pain
and the sting of the loss away from Gary
and saying get ready here we've got a
reveal all right coming up
I see do the unveil
and we have our sixth position two
nights in the sun in the corner again
it's 503 we have 504. this is very
simple is this really random
uh we're beginning to get concerned the
bishop on G1 is the culprit it's a
terrible piece because the only way that
guy gets in the game is you play a move
like F4 not everybody's cup of tea or
you have to play H3 Bishop H2 and pawns
on A2 and A7 are unprotected right so F4
idea Bishop
threatening to win upon right that would
be quite quite fun
awkward to play awkward to play for sure
we are going to take a break as the
players get ready we hope you've been
enjoying the interviews that Sabina has
been having with the players uh Gary
Kasparov for those of you who missed it
she asked him a very uh Pokey provoked
provocative question did you retire too
soon
okay we'll see you on the other side of
the break
foreign
thank you so much for joining me today
how do you feel about being back to play
over the board chess 960. I feel excited
I mean I I always liked the format the
960. it's I feel that it's uh
force you to be creative and force you
to think from the start of the game
which I like anyways in Even In
classical chess in normal chess so I I'm
pretty happy with it is it your favorite
chess variant uh yes definitely I mean I
I enjoy it quite a lot I feel that
classical chess hits anyway uh it's it's
the main the main form of Chess of
course it's hard to neglect that but but
I I do enjoy it very much though
um I mean just just how many
possibilities you have in in the in in
the 960 variants
um it's it's pretty
um makes it pretty interesting and you
won this tournament in 2021
um you're coming here having had the
experience of the tournament before but
of course it's not easy to to prepare
for the event are there some kind of
tips that you think people can use in
order to to get better at the variant to
improve I think yeah the the more you
play in general the the better you will
be because uh you you get some
experience some patterns already from
different types of positions and what
you should be doing also from the
analysis you make after the games or
before the games with other players and
so on it's it's uh experience that
you're accumulating and I think that's
helpful I try to play a little bit uh
before the tournament
specifically 960 of course it's just to
get used a little bit to the different
type types of position and and other
than that I think just your general form
uh just try to be sharp and do
uh some general preparation for that
that's that's at least how I approach it
this particular
story of 10 seconds increment
Ary classical chess more uh how do you
feel let's just say classical chess
would have to be changed
to uh chess 9lx would you feel that the
time control that classical chess has so
like 1 hour 30
is going to be a good time for for
playing these types of events or would
you keep it shorter no I think it would
be very interesting to to to give
players more time I mean to play 916
classical chess I mean with it with the
long time control
because then it would instantly become
like more serious like for the moment
it's still something of a
fun event and
but if if we play with more time I think
of course players will take it more
seriously and then
it would be more interesting because
then you would uh be forced to be deeper
and to
think more seriously about it and I
think we would produce better games and
and and we would enjoy it a bit more at
least speaking for myself because then
you can let's say in general play better
and and find more ideas and so on I
think it would be very interesting and
do you feel that the 15 minutes that you
get for the position reveal are enough
for you to get ready and how do you use
them and how important are they for your
next to play your next game it's very
little but again it's it fits I think I
think with the whole concept of let's
say it's a fun event of course we all
are super competitive and everyone wants
to win and do well but uh but it's also
a little bit for fun and and
the 15 minutes are definitely nowhere
near enough to
to get a good idea of the position
you're dealing with but just it's enough
to get a little bit of a sense like
where
um the pieces can go what tricks to
avoid how you can maybe win or lose the
game and in a few moves and and and that
kind of thing but it's it's just a very
uh
small amount of time obviously of course
but hopefully you'll be able to use it
the best you can some of the players
mentioned that in the past they've
talked to some of the other players
obviously not their opponent in that
particular round would you do you
usually do that or do you kind of
prepare on your own when you get yeah
usually I I prepare with other players I
remember in 2021 for example when I when
I won the event
I was able to use a preparation that I
made with uh with Wesley and and MBL the
three of us were looking at the initial
position and then
some very
quick specific tactic existed in the
position and we were able to find it in
in those 15 minutes and I was very
fortunate that I was able to use that in
my game against uh secretar and and I
won that game which was very important
for the
um the whole tournament situation
obviously at that at that point
um
an improvement question they have for
you in what is an exercise that you
found to be effective to improve your
visualization skills
um I think just analyzing or I mean
playing online or playing blindfold
chess obviously but
we don't I mean at least I don't do that
so often
um I almost never play blindfold chess
but I do and I'm sure most of the
players do it as well like we are we get
used to analyze
um in our heads all the time and I think
when you do it a lot uh you get better
at uh obviously at the the whole
visualization
uh in chess I think that's very helpful
and are you still focusing on analyzing
over the board or is it mostly online
oh when you talk about analyzing yeah I
mean it's I got used to to the idea of
have always having some position like
you're looking at openings for example
and you're trying
um you're taking some line or you're
trying to make some idea work and and
and then you stop your training but
somehow uh it's in your head and you
kind of playing with the position back
and forth when you're not at the board
so uh I think we all get used to that to
some extent and I think that's very
helpful for I mean because obviously the
more you do it the easier it gets and
and the better you get it visualizing do
you have a favorite player uh or a
player you'd like to play against the
most you're looking forward to play the
most in this competition yeah of course
I mean I think Gary it's uh it's the the
guy because he guy's such a legend and
growing up it was
my one of my favorite players I mean he
was like a
the god of Chess when I was 10 12 15 or
15 years old and
um I never got to play him when he was
still active but I did get to play him a
few times here in San Luis after his
retirement and uh
uh I must say it's it's always very
special when when you play him even now
because you feel that there is something
unique his energy at the board and
how serious he takes uh every game of
chess even now I think
um and again just thinking back of all
the things he did and how great he was I
think it's it's for me at least it's a
very special game
awesome well I will hope you do well uh
thank you so much for joining me and
good luck in the competition thank you
the Saint Louis chess club will be
hosting its 13th annual charity golf
tournament on October 2nd at Glen Echo
Country Club this charity golf
tournament supports the club's
Scholastic chess initiative in providing
chess to over 100 schools in the St
Louis area to sponsor this event or to
enter your team please go to
stlouischessclub.org and click on the
events tab that's the St Louis chess
club 13th annual charity golf tournament
on October 2nd at Glen Echo Country Club
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
foreign
thank you for joining us let's take a
look at our standings absolutely after
five excellent rounds of play we have
the following
we have two call leaders Livonia Rania
and Sam sevillan sharing the honors
three and a half and sharing the third
place Gary Kasparov and hikaruna Kamura
that's an interesting trailing pack
right there and then finally at 50
percent four players Fabiano caruana
Wesley sauce and shanklad and Jeffrey
Jean as Christian was pointing out
that's not a big separation of our top
eight it's Lanier and Rey that are
carrying all the sins of the tournament
and tell us about the pairings for this
Sixth and final round of the day right
so I live on Iranian will face Jeffrey
Jean both players just won their last
round exactly Fabiano caruana will play
Gary Kasparov very angry Gary kasvara
right uh the other leader Sam savian
will be playing Ray Robson no you got to
push your luck against the tournament
laggard Shanklin against Nakamura
and Dominguez against Wesley exactly
well we've got four very exciting games
Christian of those four which one would
uh you called the Marquee match I mean I
really like Fabiano versus Gary bottom a
bit biased on that one and then again we
have to give the Lords to the leaders of
the tournament so I think we have to go
with Levon versus Jeffrey at least for
the start exactly as we see again the
same three uh Gary Hikaru and Wesley
have all kind of been hanging around
pre-game looking at the current position
same as uh livon Fabi and Dominguez have
been also yes exactly
and mentioning them all they just broke
up uh the team they're getting ready to
start their games and what about Rey
where
race we finally got a partner
he was all lonely he was all lonely for
so long
and uh
during that ultimate moves we're
supposed to be trash talking I couldn't
get a word out of him that's not
everybody's cup of tea exactly he
couldn't he couldn't do it by the way
now I understand why Ray was by himself
in the first game because he was playing
uh Jeffrey oh and Jeffrey was kind of
the uh odd man out in all the pairs
right okay so now they finally it's like
a love story they found each other they
battled for one round and now they found
each other and the surprising thing that
happened in the last round was the two
players flagged in their games and
Dominguez had an equal position when he
flagged which is really shocking all the
more again I I am used to see Ray Robson
playing so many moves with just a second
and very easily playing and not losing
on time to see him flag that was really
surprising to see we didn't see linear
flag we just know that he did lose on
time we think it's a real shocking we
think he flashed well because the final
position is even you're not resigning
and it was a melee like Levon only had
eight seconds at that point so they were
going back and forth right now uh Gary
came in uh leading the tournament to in
the second round he drew Levon with the
black pieces that was a big test and
then he was better he was simply he
stood well
um maybe even winning I think that's
excessive to say had he played the move
E5 against Jeffrey so he's played well
unfortunately that hiccup that loss what
what's this mental frame like after this
in the last round time trouble finally
got to him right so Gary kasparos a road
if you will the second he can shake it
off the last game he's still playing
Amazing chess so he can bounce back no
problem and that's a new question that
we have to answer because he hasn't lost
a single game up to this point exactly
and I think might be the only
unblemished player in the tournament up
to this point he's living he's been
solid uh well on me I think Hikaru
hasn't lost either you might be right
about that yeah yes because I think in
fact I think Hikaru drew his first three
games yes uh before winning and a
drawing with Sam you are right yes so
two players uh unblemished here but uh
Fabi he just won against Rey uh in the
past he's actually done quite
successfully against Gary even with the
bad positions he's had he's he's won uh
I remember one of these things he was so
lost he was so busted there was like two
connected fast bonds about to clean and
somehow Gary scary
there we go and here we go
first moves in this in fact we have not
it's this bishop on G1 is the problem
child seems kind of a strange in this
position because we're not opening up
either Bishops that is true on the other
hand when if you if you like the London
system with Bishop to F4
H3 and Bishop H2 You're Gonna Love D4 H3
Bishop H2 you got a London system black
is likely to do the same now the thing
is you do while you're solving the
problem of the bishop on G1 and the
bishop on G8 you don't want your
opponent to Simply occupy the entire
Center hence we see D2D D4
um are we going to see another one of
those C5
games so that is the question I would
have well he's taking his time we sure
are what are we seeing on some of the
other boards yeah just one game
Dominguez Wesley because we have the
most moves in that position and whoa
whoa we said what are the weak pawns uh
pardon me what are the pawns that are
undefended A2 and A7 or and check this
out C4 takes and Wesley said
give me that pawn look at that what a
pond grubber I I am I am uh you're
probably I'm proud thank you you want to
change your pick
uh I well now that you've said it let's
go and check out Sam Shanklin in Hikaru
Nakamura because we are seeing F7 F6 in
this game as well D4 F6
wow
and regular chest they call this the
Fred
I think they call it the Fred defense
Opening Ever the word is yeah somehow it
got I think the nickname the Fred uh F
pardon me F6 and B5 Gambit yeah
is this the worst Banco Gambit ever
but for who oh he's not even a Gambit he
justify was hanging right I'm I'm not
sure Sam did as well or maybe he did
maybe he just feels that after Knight C3
this is a Tempo against the bishop if
the bishop drops back the pawn will go
to E4 F7
okay since I played F6 right you want to
keep some squares defended
and I suppose E4
I suppose you want to play Knight B6 or
maybe in Banco style let's play Asics A7
A6 okay
Fair
in Benco Style
um A4 yeah why not let's just keep this
Knight under wrap so that the Knight
doesn't have either Asics or C6 and
perhaps this is what a b a b
and we if you want I don't know I was
just about to say that don't take on B5
because your knight on A8 is going to be
hanging
there there's no Rook on A1
Ruka hey one night on A1 takes A8 that
would
that would have been uh okay
so they are following our analysis
okay and one player who just lost on
time are you kidding me I am not joking
is he still thinking on his defense
first move was F4 so and nobody else
played F4
I was thinking about it during the first
round I don't remember exactly who
played some weird moves but
is it a strategy to just play something
out of the ordinary either with white or
with black just to take your opponent
out of the opening and it seems like
this is the tendency to think whenever
they haven't analyzed a certain move to
think and try to figure out they seem to
be very aware of the fact that they
could be getting a losing position very
quickly if they're not paying attention
and not making precise moves well this
movie F4 I it really has caught uh Rey
off guard sure should he play F5 or he
should be five he should move he should
play something anything I would say at
this point move I don't care C5 F5
Knight D6 come on Ray you cannot divas
and finally D5 just inviting Bishop
takes
yeah so we could it could be a Gambit so
let's just have a quick look at what uh
Ray might have be preparing Bishop takes
A7 Knight C6 give me the bishop the
bishop would step back and in full
Gambit mode we would play Move like five
hmm
it's kind of weird it's it's too bizarre
uh a very strange Pawn sacrifice to be
sure but Christian uh jump in and tell
us what's called your fancy well first
of all the spawn sacrifice is not great
it's not no no it's it's not good D4 is
an important move in this one just to
soften up this uh situation on the queen
side as well you probably are almost
forced to go B6 you try to Target this
bishop or A7 B6 that forces the trade
Bishop takes B8 Queen takes B8 and now
we have this position sure you do have
the two Bishops but the center is in
fact quite locked so that makes the
knights quite favorable uh over the
Bishops in this one I don't like this
sacrifice I think Rey probably
overestimated we do have Bishops takes
B8 we can also do that yeah well it's
happened actually so I didn't play D4 he
took on B8 right away he took up B8
right away at Christian yeah and then
Queen takes B8 free extra Pawn still an
extra Pawn right and I'm guessing
or you can castle castle you can Castle
excuse me of course we can Castle no you
can Castle
he probably will Castle
then probably check levon's game let's
do it he is currently tied uh for the
lead uh with Sam sevillan we also had
early F6 in this game
and Jeffrey was not as Brave as Wesley
Jeffrey did not capture the part on A2
he developed his Knight showing
classical understanding
interchangeable
historians will have to debate Knight C6
um
is the worst Bishop I've seen but I
don't know we're seeing quite a number
of bad Bishops uh jumping Christian he
wants to play E5 uh that's obviously is
that the worst Bishop you've seen not
after E5 I've seen worse yes I've
definitely seen worse and interesting
nine elex I would say we've seen much
worse than that let's just wait it has
potential look it's not agreement but it
does have potential you go E5 Bishop B7
and get it out as fast as possible
uh-huh okay we'll keep an eye on this
one I just want to go back to the game
of Fabi and Gary for just a moment as we
do have some interesting things going on
also Banco style also that shows that
Gary and Hikaru were analyzing together
yeah I was about to say I just want to
make a quick comparison between nikaru
yeah we've got uh very similar uh so
take some B5 sorry we were here
um Knight to C3 Bishop went back uh your
Square F 7 A6 takes takes and we're
caught up with the players just your
knee-jerk take I mean the structure wise
black is happy but
um in terms of control over key squares
this Pawn on e4 upon on B5
what's your take someone who has played
Banco Gambit in regular chess I'm very
happy with this version with black with
black even though your Bishop isn't
joyful on the diagonal right the bishop
on d8 is not on G7 Bishop can be fine on
A5 in this uh position and maybe I can
get back the B5 Pawn uh-huh
okay
and I can Castle
thing I mean from on white side of the
board I must say this bishop on G1 still
is like
ugly as Sin I mean not to open it up
yeah exactly uh
perfectly timed there so let's say
Bishop 85 Bishop a five there's some
Bishop C4 checks also come in that's
annoying right I in fact I just for that
reason alone I'm very eager to move my
king or Castle track
I probably have to go Bishop E2 right
so I can't win the pawn back easily
not easily I mean you might win the pawn
yeah yeah I can take on E2 and go Knight
C7 okay but there's no Pawn back yeah
because you you did win the pawn on D5
which is weird right because you would
expect to have a pawn up as white but
there's no there's no extra Pawn so it's
something like castles bishop or you can
Castle too but I was thinking that you
might be eager to win the pawn on B5
well keep an eye on this one as again we
have Lavon uh aronian versus Jeffrey and
Sam sevion as our two tournament
co-leaders as Gary kasparo faltered in
round five Bishop F2 by Lavon Bishop F7
I'm assuming both players are happy to
insulate their kings castles castles
evenish
not much action going on there Sam
sevillan this was the pawn grab yeah or
upon sacrifice depending on how you look
at it but uh black is definitely ahead
in development so I should have some
conversation
in your experts
upon
just stayed in the office right boldly
boldly
um I like it I think there is
compensation there is the two Bishops
okay
I think this is the two Bishops and uh
you know
development and some kind of grips there
I'm a little bit surprised that he
defended the pawn on F4 with the movie
three instead of Castle agreed I don't
like it that agreed E3 is one of those
uh soft moves uh E4 is one of those
moves that you really do want to play so
Castle first defend the pawn if the pawn
gets attacked then yeah I can understand
that you want to play E3 but I'm
thinking that in fact you'd really
prefer to play Knight C3 and E4 and open
up the position okay that way but E3 E5
and Rey got
more than maybe now I understand why you
don't want to Castle and that's why he
played the move Knight to B3 because if
you do Castle short side you will get
hit with this battery Bishop to C7 like
for example instead of 93 if you go
castle and then you have defend with G3
and then H5 is coming and black is
definitely getting something out of that
yes and don't forget you can even Castle
long and perhaps this is what white is
hinting at leaving the King on F1 and
later down the road I will cast along
well you gotta move your queen in this
case right like Knight C3 you you're
gonna end up having to play Knight C3
Queen D1 Queen E2 it's a lot of crawling
moves strange that white hasn't moved to
the central pawns at all right just the
F1 it's so strange not not common uh
just gonna check in we may not be seeing
much of this game as the two players
Lanier Dominguez and Wesley so are not
uh playing great chess or at least
successful chess let's see what happened
in this game this was the pawn grab on
A2 by Wesley Brave
greedy F4 and let's catch up with the
players
here
oh
well it looks like a yes safe Pawn to me
I mean I don't know but as soon as these
Knights get into the game Knight C7
Knight C7 1985 and F5 are good squares
for the night oh ideal yeah yeah no
normally speaking uh is a French defense
player I've come to appreciate and love
a night on F5 as a slav defense player
kind of players
exactly exactly Sam Shanklin versus
Hikaru Nakamura my pick and this is
again not a Banco Gambit because black
did capture the pawn on D5 for uh the
pawn on B5 and let's see
a lot more moves have been made this
looks just like regular bangle but why
it's not happy Pawn
but The Bishop's not on G7 either like
how did you transfer your dark Square
Bishop from f8 to A5 yeah without moving
okay without moving either E7 or G7 a
very unusual pattern I don't know it's
just very very equal yeah very
unbalanced uh you know we would always
be allowed as a commentator by as an
annotator pardon me by saying
dynamically equal we didn't know we
didn't understand the position
dynamically equal Fabi versus Gary
Kasparov is it dynamically equal are you
not sure
still like in Black a little bit Yeah I
do too I think the the structure is very
nice and we are seeing this move Bishop
C4 check something we uh calculated
before uh Christian uh please chime
right right in what uh what's caught
your eye I was looking at this one uh
the other leader in the tournament
aronian versus Jeffrey who's coming off
that important Victory against Gary and
um this position at least I think looks
the most like a game of chess you have
the queen in a normal position creating
this battery on the B1 H7 diagonal both
sides have castled there's a rook uh
tension coming on the D file after the
move uh G6 this definitely looks like
some sort of Chess and I have to say I
like the way Black's position looks
because I have this Knight coming to see
form maybe C6 to control the center
um I like what's happening is going to
be a tense battle in the middle game
it's going to go down to the wire to the
last few minutes is going to be a battle
in this one and uh I have to say Jeffrey
must be happy with the outcome of the
opening yeah that I I agree with you the
Knight on E5 makes a pleasing impression
the other co-tournament leader Sam
sevillan Ray Robson Sam of course is
hoping that Ray will will burn his clock
and Rey has burned half his time we do
see the knights on
um B3 and C3 I think it's time that uh
one of our Central yeah exactly D4 and
the idea behind D4 is if we can get
Queen D2 castles long as actually you
forget and that's an option exactly
that's a a very very good one option we
are seeing a lot of the players playing
the moves Bishop F7 and castles short
we'll keep our eyes Fabi did not play
Bishop E2 he played King G1
interesting so
now and he wants to keep as many pieces
on the board as possible he wants a
complicated game
he is willing to give up the pawn on B5
well I'm willing to take it but I kind
of like to take it on my own terms maybe
Knight C7 but no rush okay so Queen to a
four no you can't play Queen to A4
that's about it
Queen to A4 would be embarrassing for
everybody concerned I keep forgetting to
look at the actual pieces where they're
placed what's the problem here we can't
calculate in our head you have to
actually look at the position exactly
yeah all right yeah now I'm looking at
the pieces maybe Knight B3 Knight B3
okay no I want to be aggressive I want
to go E5
I think this is what he wants I really
feel like this is what happens why is
that even
so I took it
he took it I just take it
I don't think I'm asking nicely
all right night B3 let's go uh we're
gonna take that last move back and we're
gonna play Knight B3 so that's a Tempo
on our Bishop
and I'll invite you to play E5 if you
like
um
do I do it now well you you do give up
certain squares let's go let's go let's
just see how it goes just see how it
goes yeah okay uh
I could also say that I have a long-term
compensation and instead of trying to
blast open the center I'm just going to
go H4 instead of E5
H4 I tell you we've been seeing a
remarkable number of games where H4 H5
maybe it's just you know my old ex life
experience that we never really believed
in these types of attack Alpha zero has
changed our minds but H4 that's one
tempo two template three Tempe and but
it's done to be frank there's no other
alternative at this point because you've
already played King G1 there's no more
castling yeah
you got to make a virtue out of
necessity your your Rooks trapped on H1
so H4 okay I'll develop Knight C6 H5 go
kill me castles I don't believe you H6
G6 okay he played B6 after Knight C7
he did play Knight C7 by the way and
look at the follow-up move up to B6 988
. that Bishop takes B6 well if you take
Knight A4 oh sorry I'm going to refresh
my board uh sorry apologies everybody
just refresh the board that's actually
pretty funny I like that uh I'm I want
to win a pawn but I want to win upon all
my terms I want to take it with the
Knight no I want you to take it with the
bishop no I want to take a whip tonight
if you're not listening
nice so 23 that's Force
with Nasi on this one I've got to really
be obstinate and and and play uh Bishop
before and blocks minor places look
better right oh please if you do allow
Knight B6 Knight C6 I think you're
crying you're Jane Knight B3 he played
it Knight B3 on the board yeah we expect
Bishop B4 b6s are really tempting move
to make when
think about Knight A8 as a response
yeah right but but in reality it might
just be better for black yes Knight B3
on the board and this clock's a factor I
mean Gary has been slowing slow play his
openings in early middle games but then
he tended to catch up there it is has
five minutes less than five so eight
minutes against 13 and a half okay
that has been a key a key issue for Gary
in many previous uh Fisher random and
especially encounters against Fabi and
especially yeah this is a little bit of
a nemesis for Gary uh the the matchup
with Bobby's strategy is to just put
Gary into in trouble keep as many pieces
on the board and
make the game interesting
the Chinese curse may you live in
interesting times you know
Gary is thinking after 93 I think well
is it a lot of options I'm seeing Bishop
bc6 Bishop B4 all right and Bishop C3
or you're right actually there is also
Bishop B3 and we don't want to do that
okay well yeah okay go ahead uh kill me
uh takes takes because I've got this
move C5 C4 coming yeah
guess Knight D5 wow
well in that case we're going to say
good afternoon St Louis uh Bishop takes
C3 the one move that we didn't I did not
look at Bishop takes it so he is keeping
his uh light Square Bishop so for
example Queen takes C3 Knight takes B6
Gary says look I'm a pawn up do your
worst
not a bad idea Christian
you're asking me or DeAndre
whoever will give us an answer
it was much better to hold on to that R
square Bishop with Bishop B4 which was
our first intention Bishop to B4 was
much better well it was definitely
nasi's uh first intention this Knight A8
she always wanted to play the move
Bishop B4 but Bishop takes C3 Queen
takes C3 Knight B6 is on the board the
evaluation is very close to even despite
the fact that blacks upon out yes
according to the engine black still has
an advantage but from a practical
perspective I have to say I like white
and I like the fact that I have easy
moves I'm going to go H4 I really don't
have any other Alternatives right now
so okay uh fabi's got all the time in
the world so for example go ahead and be
shaking his head and play H4 and let me
develop my my queen side you go ahead
and play H5 nope okay I can't guess
their most in this game not easily but
this move Knight A5 I do appreciate
because the bishop F7 okay the the
bishop is at least eyeballing and you
want to play B4
so Bishop dropped back to F7 Pawn went
to B4 and this is maybe why Gary
was shaking his head if we take take we
have to take with the knife can I play
Knight D7
which night eight to this
Knight eight to D7 Knight A6 he played
Knight A6 which actually attempts maybe
more aggressive so the idea is that you
do have no no no no excuse me I'll play
Bishop takes anymore
good afternoon
we're going to take on C5 and I take C5
and okay again
not impressed or is the engine
impressive no I think this whole Knight
A5 B4 was wrong the best way no no I
think he missed this move Knight E6 very
precise move by the way by the way this
Knight on A5 not for nothing it is being
a little bit I want to say unpleasantly
dominated by this bishop on F7 you don't
want to be in a situation where the
Knight just ends up isolated by itself
H3
what he just wants to put King on H2
probably and
yeah but uh
yeah very modest move no H4 H5 but H3
yeah now this is a very good way to
healthy extra Pawn healthy extra one so
let's go around the board and just take
a look at the game of Sam Savion versus
Ray Robson uh position has changed much
they're on move nine still wow they are
s playing it's so safe they both have
eight minutes versus seven so they're
spending a lot of time I really do
believe that uh Sam sevilleon does want
a castle uh long he has really been
delaying the castling shorts a queen E2
uh
those creepy crawly moves on the first
and second rank I think we've seen
Queenie too yes he is playing yeah he's
definitely pointing yeah you really I
mean and I mentioned
that the knights uh oftentimes are great
cover for the king and if you can get
your king you see it in these uh rui
Lopez you Castle short and night goes
all the way to G3 and you're very happy
that the knights are there uh it's time
a factor in this game I'm gonna guess
that raising time trouble but actually
no
um it's eight against seven
okay pretty pretty uh
let's check how the other leader is
doing live on against Jeffrey still oh
only when the lights have been exchanged
we kind of like Jeffrey's position there
for a moment we when we left it we were
just about here with the move Queen B1
G6 we were kind of expecting Rook D1 and
we thought that Jeffrey might have had a
little bit of an edge Quincy won C4
Knight D5 A6 and we've caught up with
the players
um again don't see any problems in
Black's position at all me me either
again I'm kind of uh partial if you will
to the Queen side majority please I'm
waiting for E4 you know
yeah and I will happily Park a night on
the D3 Square uh a tournament co-leader
Lavon aronian we think is slightly worse
I want to check in on Sam Shanklin
versus Hikaru Nakamura both these
players are actually faring quite well
in the tournament in the case of Hikaru
if you could pull off a win he would get
himself in a tie for first I'm pretty
sure this was this kind of event Bishop
finally made it to somewhat normal
position Bishop
five but look at this this night is I
mean this is a scrumptious scrumptious
Square Knight C6 and Christian jump in
on this one with Hikaru and Sam Shanklin
for us because again very very unusual
uh is it dynamically equal is it
dynamically equal zeros
completely absolutely yes as as
world-class commentators that's our job
to get it right and I will ask you also
why why now that you're gonna have to
reserve to our premium members the
Knight A4 great move a great way and I
have to say again once again the this is
very very complex and uh we're not going
to see much happening for a while but
Sam Savion versus Ray Robson guys this
is the big one and Rey is taking over
and he had a great chance to uh get
ahead in the attack after this move
Queen to B5
the best move is G5 no why not let's go
G4
oh Castle long and whose King is being
opened are you hmm
I forgot about that no I know
so it's just nine LX
it can really be stressful apparently I
can get on uh on that side as well
I didn't expect that I thought F5 was a
weak and perhaps you have another
problem now that the bishop is on E2
with Tempo I will go Rook to A8 and
you're gonna have to defend uh the A2
pawn and then Bishop to E8 traffic and
then that's going to trap the queen or
perhaps C4 first I think this is going
to happen because simply E4 this did not
happen one played what A4 Ray played the
move or a short Castle first
A4 this is a very strange movie
I understand it you want to play five
and soften up the C5 Pawn
wow black play F4 now just open up the
king oh yes I would have uh oh yes I
would have lost a serious wager that
White's intention was to Castle
open up the position before really seems
to
and encourage F4
the key language is perfectly safe you
have the two Bishops the requirements of
the position especially after this move
A4 that weakens the queen side is to
open up the position get to the white
king the way to do that is through F4 I
love the move F4 let's just check in on
Lavon aronian because I understand a
peace sacrifice is in the offing here uh
we just had a good enough yeah well
we're yeah exactly where did the night
because wow now when you think about the
Sam Shanklin versus
um the Dominguez game
here we have Knight F5 and check this
out follow-up idea well may I introduce
but I have Bishop G6 or Knight G6 well
Bishop G6
okay first of all the queen is hanging
so let's just find the square B8 doesn't
matter right we'll take our move back on
the next turn
um
Queen and night oh maybe maybe 96 first
first because you can't take I'll take
the piece back
correct I'm not going to take because as
you said the D5 Knight is hanging so 96
and if you move your Rook then Queen H6
comes with a tempo
and he's done it he's done it but here
what about ah you're threatening two
different mates thank you they have
Queen and Bishop
so you can't move the road I can't move
the Rook so Knight E6 he played Bishop
f8 inviting Knight takes d8 but then
it's two pieces whoops black has
beautiful minor pieces I'll say all four
of them
are still on the board
um true that
um I like Bishop Buffet just completely
killing the queen H6 idea truly truly I
think black's doing well now jump in on
this one uh Christian I seems to be
doing well yes uh Jeffrey if he were to
win back-to-back games by the way with
the black pieces well he catches up to
one of the leaders and with the other
leader also looking in shambles right
now because Ray did play that move F4
the leadership could be changing very
swiftly a lot of people could be joining
that first position looks like it's more
likely we're gonna have playoffs right
to quote uh Shakespeare uneasy where's
the crown you know being and being at
first this this day I mean Ask Gary
um I didn't pay dividends 96 Bishop f8
so hold on let's let's take on d8 or f8
yes that's the question I start to I
start to ponder maybe I want to take on
fa and still get the queen to H6 I get
the queen to H6 and maybe on a very good
day drive the night away with the move
E4 and try Bishop H4 takes F6 that's
asking a lot and black please don't move
well I well I do all my uh good business
um asking too much it's not easy to do
that right it's not easy to take that
bishopone f8 and uh pretty much agree to
the fact that you're going to be a piece
down for a while down a piece a whole
piece I understand
and do your worst for just a moment 196
maybe Knight to G6 cover up so that E4
you cannot take on F6 with the queen
anymore okay so E4 what if I go Knight
to four Knight F4 this one to F4 yes or
97 I mean 97 is also very tempting
because 92 check is unpleasant yeah I I
was trying to uh again I mean if I can
93 Maybe
93 no
now you're just being annoying that's my
job that's my job
okay okay just a whole whoa whoa whoa no
you've got Queen F4 I was a I was about
to uh play I I'm Dreaming I'm dreaming
Wishing Upon a Star you really need the
Knight on H5 to win this game truly uh
I'm not feeling it either uh Lavon is
four and a half minutes to four minutes
where's the action there is a lot of
action in a lot of places but Sam's
heavy on versus Ray Robson let's go and
there is a big big opportunity right now
so Ray I really like it I really like
the following move that I'm about to
show you I don't think it's going to
happen on the board D4 A5 was the last
move right
yes he didn't play it uh an amazing move
would have been Rook to E4
oh that is cool threatening Rook before
exactly threatening Rook to B4 and the
thing is you cannot take my Rook because
I have this little scorpion track Bishop
to E8
that is nasty but guess what Rook E4 let
me rock your world long Castle
I think it's the second time I get in a
long Castle it's not gonna break
okay room before let's go I don't know I
mean look it's not my game I mean that's
just a little bit crazy but the current
position tell me about the current
position what's going on here because
Bishop H5 I think long Castle again long
again is it time to get out of Dodge
long Castle
uh and clock times down three minutes
and 30 seconds where is he going
up what's happening I think he's asking
if maybe he's asking if he can Castle no
he can castle of course
but he wants he wants to ask if he can
Castle but I think he could Castle on
both King side and queen you're just
checking if he moved the king or
something yeah there we go
what's the role if he was to make an
illegal move is that a four feet or no
no no no no no no you just have to move
the king yes it's touch move of course
and then if you touch your Rook first
you'd have to move the Rook if it was a
legal move Castle is long Bishop takes
F3 G takes F3 uh jump in uh Christian
who's better why equal
why do I ask questions
by the way don't reach for that F3 Pawn
now that I can reach for E3 Pawn that's
the pawn you're supposed to reach he
probably should take three and uh
by the way we'll keep an eye on this one
as Gary Kasparov is down to his last
minute but he still has a healthy extra
apartment
he does but six minutes against one
that's not looking good for him that is
that is the issue
and Fabi of course is such a great
practical player he will be very aware
still quite complicated a lot of pieces
on the board one of the things I was
saying yeah this night on A5 though that
is somehow
very well dominated and Gary is sitting
there saying excuse me
not just that but maybe I can get some
threats
and let me get some threats going that's
a good practical move by Gary because
he's forcing the queen trade definitely
you know that was one of the things I
learned
if I trade off Queens early I can't
blunder IT
training off Queens uh got me a few
extra rating points
uh questions
yeah but I wasn't good at trapping my
opponents Queens
for some reason I was capturing pawns
and losing how surprises how surprising
is that because I know
how do we improve well okay seven let's
A7 Rook A7 I love it that's it
it's been working for centuries quite
unpleasant actually that pin truly and
I'm pinning myself as well but we played
G6 is that like making Luft or something
I mean what is G6 yeah it's making Luft
that's a strange move though very
strange move Rook A7 was so natural
pinning the Knight can wide plate wow
well Knight c4's Knight takes E4 right
that's the thing you cannot really get
that Knight back into play right Knight
c494 that would be nice
at least in this case we can understand
Gary's decision to play G6 he's not
allowing Rook ah check I have some crazy
ideas but it gives up more pawns E5 and
Knight C6
E5 okay I I hear I just want to bring
the Knight back but
yeah sometimes a night so takes Knight
C6 is on your agenda right so with E7
sure if I'm getting one of them back
what
what E5 and wait a minute is is E4 I
missed E4 is E4 possible it's not 97
King f8 correct
yeah I mean I'm getting two pieces for
rock but maybe okay seven at the end
maybe and pinned oh the Knight F6
there's Bishop D4 but you don't need
Gary's clock is ticking down down 20
seconds
Knight C6 on the board I'm just going to
refresh my position everybody don't get
it all about those decisions
14 seconds Gary is why did I let so much
of my clock
he is played E4
even though positions not looking good
for white five is playing for a win
coupons down but the 10 seconds are
absolutely right and now Gary is gonna
just really have to play by hand he's
just gonna you know tactics uh Bishop
takes E4 though
right well Bishop takes E4 I can play
Knight F6 I'm not only it's not just
Knight takes E4 Bishop takes E4 Knight
F6 Bishop F3 Bishop F3 Knight D5
give me your Rook give me your Bishop
give me your knight so many pieces are
hanging okay a check oh I wanted you to
play uh Bishop takes but Rook A8 check
King G7 ship D4 check you just hide on
H6 as the as the song goes on the Wild
Side I wish I could play G4 here let me
tell you what
you're not allowed to make very change
the rules of playing during we can play
98 here it's funny 98 and now maybe
oh oh talk about getting me from behind
this position with 10 seconds on the
clock no way no you're gonna lose on
time if you if they if they enter that
line Gary will lose on time for sure E5
E4 the position has exploded and even
Fabi is getting readjusted to the
situation Christian what does the engine
say about this move E4 the engine is
saying that Bishop
Knight takes C4 and black is still
better we're going straight into that
end game that we already looked at you
should probably take another Pawn take
on G6 which he does
but Black's not really risking much here
no no no unless you flank unless which
is possible which is yeah we ride that's
the way these things happen Bishop came
to E6 are we happy about that decision
well you're as happy as you can with
white because you were kind of close to
losing and now you're hoping that you
might be able to make a draw
you're hoping you might be able to make
a draw wow yes due to the limited
material nature of the position I'm
still worried about Black's King and I
have two Rooks on Eighth and exactly
possibly uh I'm also I'm looking for
some anchor squares like it would be a
dream to put my knight on F5 by the way
Rook on Rook came to A4 fabby's hitting
the night you you really want the Knight
to be anchored where do you go with that
night eight seconds for
okay that's a different anchor Square
it's protected but when I talk about
anchor squares squares that are
protected by pawns he wants to play
Bishop D5 oh yes he does he put his Rook
be careful the second rank with purpose
so does white play Rook P4 here
that's an automatic right by the way was
Bishop D5 actually a move
the previous one and Knight F6 maybe
yeah with that note okay oh I don't have
an okay no actually you do because you
take take a look forward wow like Gary
played rookie two with speed like he was
ready for Rook D4 I'm surprised that uh
because I was thinking that uh
he would be ready with King E7 but Rook
Gary thought that he wanted to put his
Rook here don't do his last minute and
20. update uh Jeffrey has blundered and
Levon is completely winning in his game
so the peace sacrifice worked out for
Lavon that's huge
Jeffrey did lose by the way we're
getting this
and we hear that Hikaru is losing to Sam
Shanklin wow
uh and again this bishop on E3 which was
bothering nobody if it gets to A3 which
it's just been played I don't know that
move rookie too
I'm not feeling just a couple of moves
we should be five years before
Bishop F5 Bishop E4 Gary has played King
to d8 what is that
he's giving well let me explain you yeah
he's trying to attack the rules losing
the D6 Pawn now well I don't know I
think he's I think it was a blunder
frankly he just been on there five
seconds
uh I think he's blunt I think it the
whole rookie two maneuver by Gary was
just wrong is simply wrong but now it's
looking like he might actually be a
checkmated somehow easily take on D6 go
King E7 and try to make a draw
yeah because you you've played it badly
as Gary yes
time to pull the brakes somehow exactly
but you know white is going to try to
win this one well for sure because again
the Knight
is on the wrong it's it's completely
wrong the the setup objectively better
oh for sure two pawns two pawns but and
exposed White's King I don't know uh
okay
oh my goodness that's just inviting
Knight H5 chats
or do you put the king king E6
whoa whoa
he hesitated now G4 G5 is coming truly
yes it is yes it is oh this is no he had
to go King E6 and Bishop C6 check
oh this is not easy oh I'm not sure
Gary okay another check to he can still
play King S6 yeah but no G5 oh G5
Knight D5
give you a check on E6 The Rook check on
A6 Knight B6 okay
I mean it's Grim it's Grim also on G5
maybe it will be too dark away the
clocks
no by the way
sorry Christian after g595 I take on D7
that's not possible you cannot do that
Wesley my pick has won his game 20
seconds each
introduction G5 not 95 it will be two
check he's done it
where does the king hide not 100 sure if
I go to E3
again Knight D5 I'm going to take E1
okay where's the Knight now 95.
nice
and Fabi has a little bit less time now
oh
yeah same idea right it's two extra
pawns pardon me yeah oh he thought that
he can only take on D5 and then you get
what that's four four oh that just
resigns there was no other option
H3 Pawn played no this this was a good
move this was very this is a good
fabulous two seconds oh my goodness one
second no he played really a second yes
I think he forgot about his clock he did
oh my gosh okay
our code tournament leader oh oh watch
out for the Checkmate it's not put in
pieces on the right squares uh we have
all decisive games so far this is the
only one left and by the way by Fabi is
setting up mates sorry where are you
hiding Rook B6 check isn't it made
already why isn't Rook B6 made oh he's
right on seven it should be
oh he wants to play Rook takes G6 which
is why he moved his King Luke 7 King
C or Rook F6
1904 94.
only move I think
but then it's king and rookie six
yes Ah that's the nice nasty and that's
the winner
funnel by Knight F6 but that doesn't do
much no this might be it yeah that wins
that was I think incredible Gary it's a
bit heartbreaking yeah
oh maybe
it should be it should be over uh we did
it with one second on his clock by the
way King B8 yep yep
uh that was a game that I don't think
Gary should have lost but guess what
five out of five
wow wow tell us what happened in the
round yeah I heard Sam said ion one I
heard levonne won so I was just watching
the same game I mean I was fascinated by
that wow let's take a look and see uh
what happened uh Sam apparently won
don't ask me how let's see exactly
because Ray we could you go to the
position where Ray played the move F4
this was the moment yes yes I think we
left it somewhere around this position
right right take take inviting this end
game okay by the way the engine is
saying maybe slightly better for black
but not by much by any means right
Knight to B7 at the same time the
knights are so tricky especially with
only a few seconds on the clock right so
you have to pay attention Bishop to C7
then we get this trade off and in fact
Rook to H1 D4 and now it's becoming a
race right
and where did it all go wrong Rook to F2
B6 Bishop to G3 is still fine in these
races the bishop to f8 this was too
passive a culprit yeah because of Knight
to F5 which he did not play C4 is fine
as well and by the way Rook takes G3
apparently was winning right now and
just simply C5 the Knight is guarding
the promotion of this pawn and you
cannot stop my pawns by uh nice on that
side so Rook to F5 Rook to d8 King to E2
G5 still of race a completely mad race
in the position but I have to say B7
Rook to d8 C6 and by the way now it's
winning Rook 28 apparently was still
somehow holding the position together
it's impossible but it's impossible
right there's no time on the clock how
much time let's see seven seconds
against 24 seconds Whoever has those
extra 10 seconds has a huge advantage in
this one because you start panicking
with black right now I mean look at this
point on B7 look at his body coming
along right I see 67 if I manage to
dispose of your bishopon G3 the game is
over right right that's the only piece
that's protecting uh against the
promotion of those spawns so it's
impossible to play with only a few
seconds again the culprit for Ray his
time is management yeah it's a problem
and maybe you can show us guys yeah what
happened in the Hikaru versus Samsung
well I was going to say the Lavon Roni
and again Lavon and Jeffrey came into
the round tight for first he Lavon is
playing against Jeffrey Zhang and Lavon
sacrifices a night we get this position
and we thought okay Jeffrey is for
Choice what happened okay
and played Rook to D4 makes sense uh
trying to use utilize the open file uh
97 Trey trade Rook Queen apartment yeah
Queen Bishop Knight okay looks like
Jeffrey's doing everything okay hello
Queen was fine until age five came
after H5
at this position is fine everything okay
no not after that
wow so G4 is coming and guess what G5
taking advantage of this pin and
suddenly it was too late and then
finally Hikaru Sam Shanklin Hikaru
Hikaru undefeated he was looking very
good uh coming into this Sixth and final
round and Sam when we left it we had
seen this position with I think it was
Knight A4 right here's where we left it
and at this point I mean zeros according
to at the the engine
and let's see what happened
okay
it's all looking good
whoa
should be even
help me out here don't go too far I
guess we do have okay we have Sam with
us well in this case uh let's turn it
over to you and Welcome to our studio
Sam Sam a much better day at the office
for you two victories with the white
pieces the first one in great style
against linear but this one was a big
one yeah yeah uh definitely like I think
I played better today yesterday than
today but I scored less points like I
usually could have made two and a half
or three yesterday and today I think I
was quite lucky to make two points I
mean the win with Lanier was very very
smooth yeah but between rounds two and
three I don't really believe I deserve
1.02 in these games probably half a
point would have been fair I was
probably a bit too adventurous against
Wesley I suspect I was fine at some
point I've been here with Hikaru uh
obviously I should never have won this
game tell us a bit about the starting
position because this is the whole so I
was working with Sam Sabian today just
I've said this before I just believe
he's the best guy to go to for the uh
specifically for the start official
random games he's the one who plays the
most fish around he's really good at it
so and this was the one we were the most
struggling with and so I just couldn't
figure out how I wanted to coordinate
the pieces right and then I really only
decided like right at the board to play
D4 we had looked at C4 E4 F3 but like
none of it was really and I think Sam
Actually played F4 if I'm not myself
with him as well this we were not we I
thought this this was reasonable that F6
was the move we were struggling with and
I thought black was fine there I guess
Ray played D5 and just gave the pawn but
D5 after like five minutes of thinking
yeah no maybe I should have played F4
just to get uh to get Hikaru out of
comfort zone because very quickly I
disliked my position like here I just
realized I'm in a bad Banker but I
didn't think I have a huge choice in the
matter
um yeah and it should be a bit worse but
I didn't think it was the end of the
world like a car told me after the game
he thought I was like basically lost
which
is felt like a little bit of an
exaggeration I definitely think the
opening went badly wrong for me but I
mean right now it's equal it didn't seem
that terrible I thought it's I couldn't
coordinate the pieces decently well
let's see if you were ever lost
um it doesn't seem like you were ever
lost it says I'm better even that I
wasn't hanging was 95 good there I was
thinking about it but I wasn't sure how
to evaluate this position so Knight
takes D5 let's say
and then what is it 1965 Bishop D5
Bishop D5 Rook A1 and C4 and this one I
was struggling to evaluate
it's not quite fast enough to coordinate
right yeah yeah yeah I thought about
this but something has a word about 95
okay seven or five yeah okay so around
here I mean I still thought my position
wasn't great apparently I was wrong but
uh yeah
um and then I think the critical moment
I thought was when he played Knight A4 I
was very surprised by this move I guess
the computer says it's fine but it
really feels like it's begging for
trouble and why is that authors like I
mean just okay so after Bishop C5 like
he could have taken on F2 and force me
to take with the rook and self pin like
a second ago and then I can and here you
know he can check on A1 or whatever I'd
like
Black's clearly fine and the only
question is can he play for a win night
I forged I took one look at it it felt
wrong I couldn't find like anything
busting it but there were some funny
lines like for example Bishop C5 yeah
this is fine knight dc5 uh
F5 Queen U2 is also possible there and
here for example like yeah Queen do two
Knight D3 I guess holds together right
is the point
yes okay so that didn't work so I had to
play F takes E5 and here for example
after Queen takes C3 do you take C5 I
don't know if your car saw this but
Knight takes E5 exists and it's very
important that after fe5 Bishop C4 black
has 96 on a check on V6 uh which Saves
the Day for him I didn't even think this
was about after 25 but which is not yeah
it seems to be very close to equality
but the way I played I thought was
totally reasonable as well like we got
this end game and then I had to choose
between I thought what I did was the
most popular because I could also play
95 instead of Bishop takes F7
um but I didn't think it was as
coordinating as well yeah Rook A4 is a
good move and black is fine Rook E4 is
quite important though yeah so I played
but I found this bishop of seven King F7
and B4 which is very well timed because
the note does not have a great place to
go to and I'm sure the computer holds
this but this does not look trivial
tonight at all no I mean those b-pawns
are incredibly scary and all it takes is
one bad move and like I mean how many
moves did it take for him to be lost
how does he save it after B6
King B5 and then Knight A5 what's Rook
d8 on my move
okay so he needed to find only moves
already and this I missed of course so I
guess if you go but even this like I
mean after Rook to you what is his next
move he cannot play King B6 Rook D6
should be no the king is close enough to
the outside pass Pawn I guess perhaps
yeah okay because he cannot play King B4
either so I guess yeah okay he's making
a draw on the pawn ending I mean that's
like
picaro's as good as anyone like finding
this stuff with zero seconds on his
clock but this still feels impossible
yeah okay so that was the way and then
he misses that in the game's over I mean
so if I'm not wrong
yes now he's just dead right he's over
yeah yeah this is all twos you know yep
yeah so decent day I mean obviously yeah
it would have been nicer if I had beaten
servian at the end of yesterday and then
um
uh also I was much better with Iranian
declined a repetition and lost but so I
felt yesterday so I got unlucky and
today I got lucky so yeah bounces up how
do you get ready for a tournament like
this and what's the most important skill
I guess you have to perform during the
game
to get the best positions and the best
results I I think that honestly the best
thing I did was just realize that Savion
was the guy to talk to I think that's a
huge step in the right direction
um but no like I did note preparation
chess wise whatsoever for this
tournament I was just been focusing on
other stuff like I have U.S Championship
coming up but I wanted to make sure I
was full of energy so just you know
exercise a lot like really this
tournament has everything to do with
form and energy levels and nothing to do
with preparation so I just wanted to
make sure that I came in with a lot of
energy well Sam's still three rounds to
go a lot to play for we'll see you
tomorrow thank you
thank you uh Sam and let's take a look
at the standings after an extraordinary
round of five decisive games let's see
how the leaderboard Shook Up
we have two co-leaders after six rounds
Le Bona ronian and sem Savion and
they're Point ahead there's some
separation of those two uh against three
players tied for third Fabiano caruana
Wesley so and Sam Shanklin who we just
had an interview falling after losing
two games in a row Gary Kasparov
suffering his first loss of the
tournament
and let's jump back with Christian uh
with a special guest Fabio a difficult
start for you that lasts with the white
piece against Carl but bounced back
immediately with two back-to-back
victories especially this one this was
not easy it looked almost unusable for
Gary at some point in the end game yet
you managed to trick him tell us a bit
about this yeah two very clean games
against Reign against very very smooth
from start to finish I played uh no I
just lost upon the opening I was dead
lost against Gary I was also probably
losing against Rey at least uh much
worse yes that wasn't I mean okay I
don't know if I was dead lost against
Gary but it was it was pretty bad once
he won the pawn and I'm just a pawn down
for nothing he also has a good structure
uh
My Hope was that he's low on time and
that's more or less why I managed to
escape and um but I have to say he
accurately took the game to the end game
you know simplified the position and you
guys got to this
uh position right now E5 yeah I was at
least happy I got this E5 I mean he has
10 seconds at this moment I was more
worried at some moment that he would
play E5 himself maybe in the middle game
and then I get a fixed weakness on e4
so yeah Knight C6 E4 actually spent a
bit of time calculating Rook 8. it was
kind of it's kind of a fun move
um yeah the thing is if
yeah like um
yeah Knight of six that's why I rejected
this finally I didn't see anything here
but the main point is that Knight of
Faith there is this trick F5 If instead
of King G7 Knight f8
90. sorry instead of King G7 Knight f8
the people use that got it then at five
it's uh at least in time trouble it's
very easy to get amazing yeah
and then if 97 97 that's a problem he
drops The Rook uh but okay I I I
didn't see this I just thought Rook C7
but this is even nicer this is very nice
so nice
so I had to avoid Temptation there
instead I went for yeah Knight of six
years very good
but he was low on time and I have six
Bishop of three it's still still a mess
94. it's not like he's completely
winning and
in time travel Anything Can Happen still
you still have two Bishops yeah yeah
then it was a safe position for him I
mean he's
he's definitely not worse he's a bit
better
but uh
but yeah I guess it's objectively a draw
and then
he made this terrible King d8 I mean
something like
I guess it's not so terrible objectively
but from practical point of view he he
starts to lose his Pawn as a pawn yeah
he can he can make a move like Bishop
five I guess yeah Rook a two yeah we're
gonna before that's that's what I was
thinking about five here is a decent
move most natural way to continue and
then okay he loses his D6 Pawn so he has
to
um now now I don't risk at all
and then I I almost flagged myself for
some moment I had like once I didn't
realize I was kind of focused on the
position I think perhaps it was uh this
point when you played Rook A7
yeah I don't know why I suddenly started
to get confused because Knight's jumping
around and
um and I realized that I could easily
lose both my pawns but then I
kind of just made a random Rook move and
figured I'll probably have a meeting at
some some moment anyway yep yeah
and I don't think he'll let it go at any
point yeah this one was precise it will
be six hours I guess it's the same thing
but yeah this the problem is he's he's
both getting mated and his Knight is in
a bad position so
um so yeah he loses here but uh okay
very very fortunate and today
Bobby at one point still behind the
leaders sorry feeling about your chances
going into the last three
yeah I'll just have to have a very big
final day if I want to fight for first
place that's pretty clear and I do play
both of them so that gives me some hope
livon and yeah level and Sam uh I'm not
sure which order but uh my last three
will be love on Sam and Jeffrey and I
guess they're all I think Jeffrey is
also doing decently so it's not going to
be an easy final day but I didn't think
any day would be easy I mean everyone is
very capable here everyone's very strong
guys any questions no just our
congratulations Fabi for a nice win over
Gary there I think he just have played
him very nicely in the end game
um we we've been talking about a very
very very briefly uh playoff scenarios
it's the worst playoff because yeah two
players tied for first what would happen
if two players are tied for first let's
see so there's going to be the two rapid
games with 10 minute plus two second
increments got it that crank will be
same for both games
right so they flick the colors that
makes sense that's nice and if they're
still tight they're going to have chest
960 are my given game
five minutes for white four for black
black wings if it ends in a draw I think
I definitely new back rank drawn I think
I definitely take the extra minute I'll
go with why you know you know because I
I want uh the extra time and uh our
pairing is a peek ahead for our first
round of uh the third and final day
Wesley so will be playing the tournament
leader livon aronian big game and if he
wants to fight for the first he's gonna
try to win exactly bring him back to
Earth
will try to bounce back tomorrow he's
playing linear Dominguez right we Robson
playing Sam Shanklin Gary playing
another tournament leader Sam Savion
Professor versus student uh youth our
young Samsung tournament leader and
Jeffrey will be playing Fabiano lovely
and uh Christian was the guest speaking
of another player that bounced back with
back-to-back victories after a loss in
the first round in the fourth round the
first round of today's Wesley so with us
Wesley I want to talk to you about this
game thanks for having me in the fifth
round against Sam Shanklin because yeah
this was very very interesting yeah
sacrifice E5 did you expect this well I
was actually following Hikaru nakamura's
game like it's a good lead he was
getting good position and you were
getting good position as well yeah like
I just looked at the board at his board
on the table and I noticed that we have
the exact same position after A6 and so
I just played before very quickly
without thinking but I didn't
discernment
is that technically cheating
but uh no I mean in the Olympics five
years ago actually Sam and I have the
exact same position until move 20
against the Chinese guys in the last
round so but in the tournament I've been
analyzing with Gary and Hikaru so we
tend to get similar positions
how did that experience has been for you
I
feel great I
I it's a great
honor and privilege to analyze with the
living legend Gary Kasparov and just to
see the way that he's inside the way his
mind works and then the way he looks at
and thinks of certain positions he's
still very sharp and you know he's got a
lot of experience he knows his
principles well so very good was I
should have done it much sooner because
previous years he was always working
with Peter Peter yes so thank God but uh
yeah I mean he's still sharp he's
playing very good chess so it's uh
incredible but did that inspire you
yesterday we actually named an opening
Gambit after you that B5 move followed
by Bishop E5 that gave you the 13 move
Victory oh it's Jeffrey yeah but that
was uh was very nice game
uh influence at all
no uh not not that time but uh but
pretty much everywhere else yeah yeah
not that time but still I I think uh and
you learn a lot from analyzing with Gary
absolutely let's talk about this game so
E5 an interesting Pawn sacrifice and we
got to this position how did you assess
it by the way
well at this point I thought Sam played
very well I thought E5 was very good in
mode 5. because otherwise again film
banned but I thought they should take
with the queen on move eight maybe
because uh
the idea is that Queen takes and then
once the Queens are exchanged idea is
that you move the
okay Knight takes the idea to remove the
bishop light squared Bishop real quickly
and he castles long
so and then he gets really fast
development so I thought if I was a
brilliant move but I was very surprised
when it took me the Knight because now I
get to pin him
and uh it's not so easy it was this
funny moment when he actually could have
Castle along at the end yeah I mean he
should have done this yeah clearly and
then black has the
initiative but maybe he didn't even
consider this he just didn't he just
didn't perhaps he didn't yeah I I would
be surprised if he did because it's uh
hard to move but here yeah Castle yeah I
think he made some mistakes like this
this seems to happen yeah yeah I thought
I was thinking of slower mode here but I
have to go for it because when when else
am I going like I have to attack and
you sensed at that moment you timed it
perfectly with this move F5 yeah so okay
ethics was actually a mistake yeah yeah
it seems to have uh won the game not
Rook G3 okay E3 yeah Rook E3 that's key
move uh Queen H5 broke H3
and what about Queen G5 maybe four games
attempt was simply 94. yeah everything
comes with Tempo yeah somehow there have
been many so many mistakes in this
tournament I think also the short time
control but here he played 95 very
quickly Bishop E2 was okay for black
Bishop takes E2 I was gonna play Rook up
seven then he takes
probably makes a draw yes we're not
winning another piece
one but 95 was a blunder after that why
it's just completely winning he probably
missed this move Queen to D2
is that how you feel about it yeah
probably he just saw
you cannot you can Fork a queen in a
rook and he just went for it without
thinking and if you go Queen to D4
perhaps Queen to G7 now yeah E2 I have
to protect that uh Pawn Yeah so uh yeah
I gotta make the door but the queen
Little Queen G7 Rook F7 I guess instead
of Queen G6 on move 24
I guess
25 and the position is still extremely
difficult right after Rook F3 there's a
lot of checkmates coming along yeah for
sure but black could defend but I feel
generally determine players are
including me are making tons of mistakes
game against Evian with very weird like
I thought I had a very bad position
after move two move three
the
much much much better after after two
days going in the final day you probably
start understanding what's going right
what's going wrong what are the
adjustments that you're going to make
going in the final day to to make that
push
well if I want to fight for first place
I gotta start winning games after game
because uh I mean I had a very slow
start and then
so and you know level one is playing
very well
so I'm gonna have to
you know we win a lot of games and try
to take risks and
try to try to attack that's uh that's
the thing but um
I think I feel in this tournament it
feels like there's always a different
winner every single year like now
everyone is winning linear one one year
so uh it's uh it's interesting I'm still
not clear how the best way is to prepare
for chess 960
uh
but uh but I guess you just gotta show
up sharp and you gotta have good time
mad time management but I still look
very much too
forward to and I think and with Gary
tomorrow and whatever happens happens
you know this is this tournaments a
showdown after all it's uh more of an
exhibition but
I guess a player you wanna he wanna we
wanna yeah you got you gotta win at some
point I've been playing this tournament
for for this thing with my fourth well
you you did win a world championship in
just 960 so you definitely have a lot of
experience in this uh format yeah time
control was slightly long longer at that
point but
yeah it Wesley will let you get some
rest go uh get ready for tomorrow we'll
see you tomorrow yeah thank you
Christian
thank you uh Wesley indeed and let's
just take again again uh Gander at the
standings says uh we've seen a lot of
decisive games in in 9lx going into the
last day we have two leaders livon
aronian and San sevillan full point
ahead rest of the field a little bit of
a gap yep at one point gap Sharon third
Fabiano caruana Wesley so and Sam
Shanklin both of those all three of
those players pardon me are going to be
looking for a big third day if they want
to tie for first
and with the 50 yes Jerry casparov and
Hikaru Nakamura I'm sure they're both
smarting thinking oh things could have
been better and uh very unlucky Lanier
Dominguez and Ray Robson at the end as
we uh close our broadcast for today but
some final thoughts of again very bloody
a lot of decisive games Christian yes
absolutely uh unpredictable as well
Topsy Turvy as Wesley was pointing out
as well a lot of blunders and we're
expecting more blunders tomorrow as well
but I have to say this is anybody's
tournament at this point the Levon and
Sam are not running away with it and
there's a pack of hungry wolves closely
following behind so it's going to be a
fantastic day three and final day here
in St Louis at just 90x thank you
Christian yes indeed and once again that
was great fun I mean that was so fun
all decisive results crazy crazy stuff
thank you all for joining us we'll see
you tomorrow same time same channel as
we will be crowning a winner tomorrow
thank you and see you tomorrow good
night
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited